Hey everybody, welcome to our talk show. What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it?
大家好，欢迎来到我们的谈话节目。这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？
What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it? Okay, we just we don't have a band or tell it right now on the show I hope that you would just not talk and just say hey welcome to smartless so talk show for you guys a listen show for me Yeah, sure got it. Welcome to smartless How's everybody doing today? At a great day.
这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？这是什么？好了，我们只是目前在节目里没有乐队，也不用向大家介绍，我希望你们就别说话了，直接说嘿，欢迎来到 SmartLess。所以这是为你们准备的谈话节目，为我准备的访谈节目。对，没错，知道了。欢迎来到 SmartLess。大家今天过得怎么样？度过了美好的一天。
At a great morning. Yeah. But Sean, you've got to tell around your neck. Why is that? It's a blanket, Jay. Oh, are you in an overly air conditioned department? I certainly am. Oh, that's high-class problems.
度过了美好的早晨。对。不过肖恩，你脖子上围了个东西。那是为什么？那是条毯子，杰伊。哦，你在一个空调开得太足的部门吗？我确实在。哦，那是高级烦恼。
What's the temperature in New York City today? It's hot. It's 80, 90, I don't know. No kidding. And so you're in a place that's so hot, but you're wearing a blanket. Well, because Scottie's at the gym and he, when he gets home from the gym, it's like, you know, it's too hot without you. Do you know, that seven of the hottest days on record on this planet have been in the last week? Yes. Yes. I know. And it's crazy. And it's crazy.
纽约市今天气温多少？很热。有 80、90 度吧，我不知道。不是吧。所以你呆在一个这么热的地方，却围着毯子。哦，因为斯科蒂在健身房，他，他从健身房回家的时候，就像，你知道，没有你太热了。你知道，有记录以来地球上最热的七天里，有七天都在过去的一周里吗？是的。是的。我知道。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。
Because of people like you. No, because because Scotty likes you to have all your. Because Scotty does, because Scotty does want to be hot when he comes home from the gym. No, no, no, or else. Take that. That's true. Take that. Polarize cap.
因为像你这样的人。不，因为，因为斯科蒂喜欢让你拥有所有。因为斯科蒂是，因为斯科蒂确实想在从健身房回家时觉得热。不，不，不，不然的话。接着这个。那是真的。接着这个。极地帽子。
But wait, you love this. I think I told you this Jason before, but I don't know if I told you well. The, you know, when Scotty and I were at a restaurant the other night and we got in a fight about, not a fight, just a discussion about the weather, like the weather app versus the internet, I always look at the internet for the correct thing and he's like, no, just use your iPhone app, the weather app on your iPhone. I'm like, it's never right. It always says 70 or 80 and it's going to rain and it doesn't.
但是等等，你很喜欢这个。我想我以前跟你说过这个，杰森，但我不知道我有没有跟你说清楚。你知道，上次我和斯科蒂在一家餐厅的时候，我们吵了一架，也不是吵架，只是讨论了一下天气，比如天气 App 对比互联网，我总是看互联网上的准确信息，而他说，不，就用你的 iPhone App，你 iPhone 上的天气 App。我说，它从来都不准。它总是说 70 度或 80 度，然后要下雨，结果却没有。
I go out to the internet, go to the internet. And then just to defuse the tension, when it gets real hot like that between us, like in a public place, I always look to his left to an imaginary person and I go, try living with it. Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God.
我去互联网上找，去互联网上。然后为了化解紧张气氛，当我们之间气氛变得像那样非常紧张时，比如在公共场合，我总是看着他左边的一个想象中的人说，去过这种日子试试吧。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
Wait, so when you go to the internet, what do you- I go to acu- other, I go to acu- other, that's better than the app. Where do you go on the internet, Sean? I go to act you whether that's better than the app. Where do you go on the internet, Sean? I go to whether, whether channel. Well, that's, that's, that's, there's an app for that. Yeah, but it's just like I just go to the, I just look it up. By the way, I can't imagine you ever fighting with anyone.
等等，所以当你上网时，你— 我去 acu- 其他，我去 acu- 其他，那个比 App 更好。你在网上哪里查，肖恩？我去 act you weather，那个比 App 更好。你在网上哪里查，肖恩？我去 weather，weather channel。嗯，那，那，那，那有个 App 可以用。对，但它就像我直接去，我只是查一下。顺便说一句，我无法想象你跟任何人吵过架。
I was talking about you the other day with somebody and I, I, I said with all seriousness, I've never seen you in a bad mode. I've never seen you angry. I've never seen you in a bad mood. I've never seen you angry. I've never seen you fight, obviously, with anybody you're... You saw me, I got angry with you three years ago. What did I do? What did you do?
我前几天跟别人聊起你，我，我，我很认真地说，我从来没见过你心情不好。我从来没见过你生气。我从来没见过你心情不好。我从来没见过你生气。我从来没见过你跟任何人吵架，显然，你……你见过我，我三年前生过你的气。我做了什么？你做了什么？
Nothing, we were just arguing about something on the phone, and then we called each other after, and you said, I think that was our first ever fight. And I said, yeah, and you smiled, and you laughed, and you said, how does it feel? God, I don't remember. You guys got a little bit...
没什么，我们当时只是在电话里争论某件事，然后我们后来给彼此打了电话，你说，我想那是我们有史以来第一次吵架。我说，是的，你笑了，你笑着用说，感觉怎么样？天哪，我不记得了。你们当时有点……
I remember you guys got a little scrappy. You know, we got a discussion. But I have been angry like twice. There's only like one or two people in my whole life that can actually push me in a corner so bad that when I come out, I sound like the most brilliant like speaker in the world. Like when my buttons are pushed so much,
我记得你们当时有点针锋相对。你知道，我们讨论了一下。但我真的生过气也就两次。我整个人生中其实只有一两个人能把我逼到如此绝境，以至于当我爆发时，我听起来就像世界上最才华横溢的演说家。就像当我的痛点被疯狂触及时，
laser focus. I am so, I sound so smart. Otherwise. Yeah, I sound so smart. Otherwise. Yeah, I mean, like watching you in the play, you know, your character gets pretty, he's, he's not a happy guy. Yeah, I think I get it out in that way. That was really interesting to see. So you know how to, how to be grumpy.
注意力高度集中。我太，我听起来太聪明了。否则的话。对，我听起来太聪明了。否则的话。对，我的意思是，就像看你演的戏剧，你知道，你的角色变得相当，他，他不是个快乐的家伙。对，我想我是通过那种方式发泄出来的。看那个真的很有趣。所以你知道怎么，怎么变得暴躁。
Yeah. You just never are. Why are you so fucking happy? You know what then, and then that's why you guys are such a great, yeah, because I'm grumpy all the time. But I have, I'm not upset about anything. I just, I think my rest is just, grump.
是的。你只是从来不这样。你他妈的为什么这么快乐？你知道吗，然后，这就是为什么你们俩这么棒，对，因为我总是暴躁。但我，我对什么都不生气。我只是，我觉得我的默认状态就是暴躁。
Yeah, Amanda's always asking me, well, are you okay? You're in a good mood? Yeah, yeah, I'm just chill. All the time. I'm always chill. You're always super chill. Yeah.
是的，阿曼达总是问我，嗯，你还好吗？你心情很好？对，对，我很冷静。一直都很冷静。我总是很冷静。你总是超级冷静。是的。
So you're in a constancy of chillax, would you say that I'm always chillaxing. And then you know what? But you, but Sean, you're always, you're always obviously happy. I'm never, obviously, well, not never, but I'm, when I'm, I'm, I'm just sort of normal. You're never normal. You're always happy. Oh, that's going on. Honestly, things that dumbest cliche answer, but it's the truth. I think the way I grew up, I grew up so shit, shit poor. We all did in my family. That sounds so dumb, but I walked down the street
所以你处于一种持续的松弛状态，你会说我一直在松弛。然后你知道吗？但是你，但是肖恩，你总是，你显然总是很快乐。我从来不，显然，也不是从不，但是当我，我，我只是有点正常。你从来不正常。你总是很快乐。哦，这还在继续。老实说，这是最蠢的陈词滥调答案，但这是实话。我想我成长的方式，我小时候穷得叮当响。我们家里所有人都是。这听起来很蠢，但我走在街上
every day going, oh my God, I don't have to go through a winter in Chicago without any heat. I don't have to go without food. I don't have to go without all these things that we didn't have as kids. That's still tangible to you. That's still... Yeah, I'm just like, it's my work hard and it's why I'm grateful every day.
每天都在想，哦天哪，我不用在芝加哥没有任何暖气的冬天里熬过去了。我不用挨饿了。我不用经历我们小时候没有的这一切。这对你来说仍然很真实。这仍然……是的，我只是觉得，这就是我努力工作的动力，也是我每天都心存感激的原因。
Huh. Pretty good. And that's the end of the show. Well, what's your, you're always kind of just normal. Like when you're happy about something you can tell, when you're upset about something you can tell. Yeah. But you're usually right in the middle, like me.
哈。挺不错的。节目到此结束。嗯，你的，你总是那种很正常的状态。就像你对什么事情高兴时你能看出来，你对什么事情心烦时你能看出来。对。但你通常就在正中间，就像我一样。
You're not, you're not on some... I've never seen... I feel like Sean might be taking something. I wish. Well, I think about him every once in a while. But will, I've never seen you really, I see you hot when you get opinionated about something. I've never seen you angry at a person.
你没有，你没有处于某种……我从来没见过……我觉得肖恩可能嗑了点什么。但愿如此。不过威尔，我从来没见过你真正，我看到你对某事发表高见时会很激动。我从来没见过你对某个人生气。
Well, this is the other thing that I have to, and I've been warned by Alessandra and even by my ex by Amy, which is just. Stop hitting people. No, Amy used to turn me out. Okay, I get about, I go, like, get heat about that. She just looks and she go, tone. I go, sorry. And so I get nothing will get me hotter than that. I know. I tell her to relax. But I don't get it. If somebody just said tone. Yeah. I'd be like, oh, really?
好吧，这是另一件事，我必须承认的，而且亚历山德拉甚至我的前妻艾米都警告过我，那就是。别打人了。不，艾米以前会把我纠正过来。好吧，我懂，我对此会很有火气。她就会看着我说，语气。我说，抱歉。所以没有什么比这更能让我火大的了。我知道。我让她放松。但我不明白。如果有人只是说语气。对。我会觉得，哦，真的吗？
What kind of tone would you get? But you see, I don't take it that way. I don't take it personally that way. Because in that moment, I go like, oh, the other person's going through is being subjected to my, to my shit. And so like, I got it. Because that's a blind spot, you know, is like, I get in this thing where I go, I'll hear somebody in a relationship or whatever or somebody in my life and they'll say, hey,
你会觉得是什么语气？但你看，我不是那种方式看待的。我不是那种针对个人的方式来看待的。因为在那一刻，我会想，哦，另一个人正在经历、正在承受我的、我的烂脾气。所以就像，我懂了。因为这是一个盲区，你知道，就像我会陷入这种状态，我会听到某个恋爱中的人或者我生活中的某个人说，嘿，
you said that and bubble a balloon and go, boy, I really didn't see it that way. I'm really sorry. And yeah, I appreciate getting heads up like that too. And I also don't want people walking on eggshells around me. I just assume that no one's paying any attention to me. So I can just be just level and normal. But I realize that, well, if I'm not sending signals that I'm in a good mood,
你刚才那么说了，巴拉巴拉，然后我想，天哪，我真没那么想。我真的很抱歉。而且是的，我也很感激能听到这样的提醒。而且我也不希望人们在我面前如履薄冰。我只是假设没有人注意到我。所以我可以保持平和与正常。但我意识到，好吧，如果我没有发出我心情很好的信号，
people might be uneasy around me or anyone else that might, you know. I heard that the people over at Aggregate, all the staff got together. You know what they're gonna call the company now? Here comes the eggshell productions. Oh I thought you're gonna say aggravated. Oh Agrival that would have been better. All right, let's get to our guess. Okay. I love this person. I'm so excited for you guys to meet this person
人们可能会对我和可能接触到的任何人感到局促不安。我听说 Aggregate 那边的人，所有的员工都聚在一起了。你知道他们现在给公司起名叫什么吗？来了，鸡蛋壳制作公司。哦，我还以为你要说 Aggrival 呢。哦，Aggrival 那样会更好。好了，让我们有请我们的嘉宾。好的。我超爱这个人。我太为你们能见到这个人感到兴奋了
We're all fans of this person. Okay, and Jason just a little hud's up. She was on your list too. I found out really You stole her? I did, I stole her. She's gonna fit right in here since she isn't a stranger to dealing with idiots. In fact, some could agree, some could argue, sorry, she's made a career of it. Oh, he's written this. I read it, I totally read it. I read it, she's. And got, she's fitty. Right, me, I did.
我们都是这个人的粉丝。好的，杰森，给你提个醒。她也在你的名单上，我发现的真的吗？你抢了她？对，我抢了她。她会非常适合这里，因为她对对付白痴并不陌生。事实上，有人会同意，有人会争辩，抱歉，她已经把这当成了职业。哦，他写了这个。我读了，我完全读了。我读了，她是。而且，她是好样的。没错，我，我读了。
Oh my god, that's so funny. In college, she had a competitive backstroke with the William and Mary athletic tribe before eventually deciding to dive into the mean waters of political campaigning. And though it would be difficult to be the most mean to employee at the White House, she's gotta be in the top five. I'm a big fan of the super smart, super cute ginger.
哦天哪，太搞笑了。在大学里，她在威廉与玛丽学院的竞技部落运动队进行过竞技仰泳，之后最终决定涉足政治竞选这片波涛汹涌的水域。尽管要在白宫当最惹人讨厌的员工很难，但她绝对能进前五。我是这位超级聪明、超级可爱的红发女郎的超级粉丝。
Ginger. It ends all in ginger. It ends all in ginger. It ends all in ginger. Oh, I know. I love the transition from backstroke. I was a mediocre college swimmer. I'm just gonna acknowledge at the start here,
红发女郎。最后都落在红发女郎上。最后都落在红发女郎上。最后都落在红发女郎上。哦，我知道。我喜欢从仰泳的过渡。我曾是一名平庸的大学游泳运动员。我在这里一开始就要承认，
you're in politics, so thank you for that. And I also learned a little conversation about happiness. I thought you were like the superstar Backstrucker. No, I was a mediocre. You think you're in shape until you try to swim. I mean, any kind of swimming is really impressive because boy, you try two laps and you're down. And it's the hardest thing to do. That in full corp as well.
你从事政治，所以谢谢你。而且我也了解了一点关于幸福的对话。我以为你是那种超级巨星仰泳运动员。不，我只是个平庸的。当你尝试游泳之前，你会觉得自己身材很好。我的意思是，任何种类的游泳都真的很令人印象深刻，因为天哪，你游两圈就累趴下了。这是最难做的事情。全心全意也是如此。
Jen Saki, Jen Saki, nice to meet you. I'm so glad to hear it. Nice to meet you. What are your thoughts on treading water as a form of exercise? Because I've heard that that's like involves water polos. It is hard. Now, when you, I was a lifeguard growing up and you have to be able to tread water for a certain amount of time. I don't know if any of you are aspiring lifeguards, but you, I was a lifeguard growing up, and you have to be able to tread water for a certain amount of time. I don't know if any of you were aspiring lifeguards,
珍·萨基，珍·萨基，很高兴见到你。很高兴听到这个。很高兴见到你。你对把踩水作为一种锻炼方式有什么看法？因为我听说那有点像水球。这很难。你看，我年轻时当过救生员，你必须能够踩水一定的时间。我不知道你们当中有没有人立志成为救生员，但你，我年轻时当过救生员，你必须能够踩水一定的时间。我不知道你们当中有没有人立志成为救生员，
but you might have to practice. It's part of the journey to save people. Let me tell you, I went with my friend once a long time, and I went on a kid to this lake. And in the middle of the lake, there was this lake. You could lay out this, hang on, hang and stay with me. Sorry. This little platform that you could swim to,
但你可能得练习。这是拯救人们的过程的一部分。我跟你讲，很久以前我和我的朋友去过一次，我和一个孩子去了这个湖。而在湖的中央，有这样一个湖。你可以躺在上面，等一下，坚持住，听我说。抱歉。这个小平台你可以游过去，
and we got out there, and I couldn't swim back. I panicked. I had a grab on his swim to and we got out there and I swam, I couldn't swim back, I panicked, I had a grab on his back and he had a swam. Well this is the plot of Stand By Me. What are you talking about? You just made that up? And then we found a dead body. Jen Socky, I'm so excited that you're here. I'm excited to be here.
我们游到了那里，然后我游不回去了。我惊慌失措。我不得不抓住他的背游去，我们游到了那里，然后我游，我游不回去了，我惊慌失措，我不得不抓住他的背，然后他游了。这不就是《伴我同行》的剧情吗？你在说什么？你这是现编的吧？然后我们发现了一具尸体。珍·萨基，我太兴奋你能来了。我也很高兴能来。
I'm a huge fan and happy third birthday. No way. No, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. It's bananas that you even know that we're on the planet. I watch you every single day. I'm totally star struck. Your world is far more exciting and interesting and respectful than ours. Respectable than ours. Yeah. Well, yeah. Well, their her side. Shall we? Her side. Her side. Yeah. Yeah. No, I want to first of all, I just want to well, there's her side. Shall we say her side?
我是个超级粉丝，祝你三岁生日快乐。不会吧。不，谢谢你。谢谢你。谢谢你。谢谢你。你们竟然知道我们还在这个地球上，这太荒谬了。我每天都看你们节目。我彻底惊呆了。你们的世界比我们的世界要刺激得多、有趣得多，也更受人尊敬。更受人尊敬。是的。好吧，是的。好吧，她们那边。我们开始吧？她们那边。她们那边。是的。是的。不，我首先想，我只想，好吧，那边有她们那边。我们可以说她们那边吗？
Her side. Yeah, yeah. No, I want to first of all, I just want to get this out of the way, the dumb stuff at the beginning. How many people pronounce your last name wrong? And dude, oh God, I mean 80%. What do they say?
她们那边。是的，是的。不，我首先想，我只是想把这个抛开，开头那些蠢事。有多少人把你的姓氏读错？天哪，我的意思是 80%。他们怎么读？
Pesui, Pesale, Saki, they add letters in between. And then I'm sympathetic to hard names, and I really try hard to pronounce them, but I over-ask sometimes had to pronounce names as a result. Yeah, I'm sure, I'm sure. How are you liking, how are you liking doing a show? What's the schedule like? Is it not so easy?
Pesui，Pesale，Saki，他们在中间加字母。然后我对难念的名字很同情，我真的很努力去念对它们，但结果我有时会过度纠结怎么念名字。对，我确信，我确信。你觉得怎么样，你觉得做节目怎么样？日程安排是怎样的？是不是没那么容易？
Oh, it's great, I love it. I mean, it's different because my show shows on Sundays, I have another show on Thursday as a peacock show, and I would do this letter in a couple different things. But yes, on peacock, you can stream it. But on-sense, there's a lot of build up to the Sunday show. So I wouldn't say the schedule is, and I appear in other people's shows too, so it depends on the week. But it's just, it's different from the White House
哦，太棒了，我很喜欢。我的意思是，这很不同，因为我的节目在周日播出，我周四还有另一个节目，是个 Peacock 的节目，我还会做这封信和一些其他不同的事情。但是是的，在 Peacock 上，你可以播放。但是—不过，周日的节目有很多筹备工作。所以我不会说日程安排是，而且我也出现在别人的节目里，所以这取决于那一周。但这和白宫很不一样，
where I was just in my last job. Because then it was all about the briefing every day. And you work 24-7. It's not like that anymore. But I do spend a lot of time with this amazing team trying to figure out what unique we're going to say, what guests we're going to have on. It's been a lot of time reading.
那是我上一份工作。因为那时候每天都是简报。而且你是 24 小时连轴转。现在可不是那样了。但我确实花了很多时间跟这个了不起的团队一起琢磨我们要说些什么独特的观点，我们要请什么嘉宾。花了很多时间阅读。
So it's just a different schedule, but it's not as insane as it used to be. Well, so speaking of the insane times, you're at the White House. And what was that? What was that like? Where were you when you got the call? Well, yeah, where were you when you first of all,
所以这是一个不同的日程安排，但没有以前那么疯狂了。那么，说到疯狂的时光，你在白宫。那是怎样的？那是怎样的？你接到电话时在哪里？好吧，是的，你当时在哪里，
when you got the call? What was it like? What were you when you got the call? I was just gonna say is the answer Peter Ducey. I don't know, people always ask me that. I mean, I love that, I't know. People are asking that. I love that. I love that.
当你接到电话时？那是怎样的？你接到电话时在哪里？我本来想说答案是彼得·杜西。我不知道，人们总是问我这个。我的意思是，我喜欢那个，我不知道。人们在问那个。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。
Go ahead. That was not your question. Well, we can do that. Where were you when you got the call that they were offering you that job? Do you remember that? How that went down? Yeah. So I was a bridesmaid twice before I was a bride as they like to say.
请说。那不是你的问题。好吧，我们可以那样。当你接到他们提供你那份工作的电话时，你在哪里？你还记得吗？那是怎么回事？对。所以正如他们喜欢说的那样，我在成为新娘之前当过两次伴娘。
I was the runner for this job twice, which is relevant mainly because a lot of times people don't get jobs. And then sometimes it works out, right? And that's always, that's a, was a big lesson to me. But I was working on the transition. There's a presidential transition, right, between every president. And I just felt like I was working in the private sector.
我是这份工作的候补两次，这之所以重要，主要是因为很多时候人们得不到工作。但有时事情会成功，对吧？这总是，对我来说是个深刻的教训。但我当时在从事交接工作。每个总统之间都有总统交接期，对吧？我当时觉得自己是在私营部门工作。
I was, I was a, working for CNN. but I felt like I wanted to do something for government in that period of time post Trump. I didn't know what it was. So I was working on that. And I needed done, who is still one of President Biden's closest advisors. I needed done right now. Right, right. She's got a fabulous, doesn't it a great name?
我当时在为 CNN 工作。但我觉得在特朗普之后的那个时期，我想为政府做点什么。我不知道那是什么。所以我一直在做那个。而阿妮塔，她至今仍是拜登总统最亲密的顾问之一。我当时需要阿妮塔。对，对。她有个极好的名字，不是吗？
I love that name. She called me and she said, would you be interested in being considered for this job? And I said, I'd be honored, but I really have to talk to my family about it, which sounds a little 1950s, but the truth is, no, I mean, some people think, you know, you're a woman, just do it. I believe that, but I have two little kids. I still do. I had them then as well. And I wanted to factor that in and see how that would be. But then fast forward, she called me and said, can you go see the president, President elect tomorrow or the next day or something? And so that, that was all, it was kind of a little bit of a short journey.
我喜欢那个名字。她打电话给我，问我有兴趣被考虑这份工作吗，我说我会感到荣幸，但我真的必须和我的家人谈谈，这听起来有点像 50 年代的风格，但事实是，不，我的意思是，有些人会觉得，你知道，你是个女人，直接干吧。我相信这一点，但我有两个小孩子。我至今还有。我当时也有。我想把这个因素考虑进去，看看会怎么样。但后来快进到，她打电话问我，你能明天或后天去见见总统、当选总统吗？所以，这一切，有点像是一段短暂的旅程。
Okay. Can I ask you, was one of the considerations when you said I have to talk to my family? Obviously, you have to talk to your family, no matter who you are when you take a job like that because it's so all encompassing. And it's going to, it threatens to take a lot of your time and a lot of your energy and a lot of your focus. And so you've got to say to your, your partner and your kids and whatever. And all of a sudden, it's a public. Well, that was going to get to that.
好的。我能问一下，当你说了“我必须和家人谈谈”时，其中一个考量是——显然，无论你是谁，当你接受这样一份工作时，你都必须和家人谈谈，因为它是如此包罗万象。它会威胁到要占用你大量的时间、大量的精力和大量的关注。所以你必须对你的伴侣、你的孩子等等说。而且突然之间，它变成了一个公众……好吧，我正要说到这。
So what I was saying was two part, which is the first part is it's a big job, but although we know that. But also, did you sort of give you some pause knowing that the environment had changed dramatically on in November 2016, everything changed the way that we approached and where all the norms were thrown out the window and all of a sudden everything is on the table or off the table depending on how you look at it.
所以我要说的是两部分，第一部分是这是一份大工作，尽管我们都知道这一点。但同时，你是否也有所顾忌，因为你知道自 2016 年 11 月以来，环境发生了巨大变化，一切都变了，我们对待问题的方式变了，所有的常规都被抛到了窗外，突然之间一切都摆在台面上，或者根据你的看法被排除在台面之外。
And now we live in a different world. It's very changed. It's without grace. It's without norms. It's without respect for all that kind of stuff is thrown out. Was that a major consideration? Sorry for the long question. Oh no, I know this is going to sound crazy, but no, I didn't think that that
现在我们生活在一个不同的世界里。它已经面目全非了。它没有风度。没有常规。没有尊重的概念，所有这些都被抛弃了。这是一个主要的考量吗？抱歉问题有点长。哦不，我知道这听起来很疯狂，但没有，我没想过那个。
I lit was living that in the sense that I was consuming all of this vitriol just like everybody was, but I didn't apply it to myself. And actually even when I started the job working as the press secretary, you know, because it was the height of COVID and I we didn't I didn't go out anywhere. I didn't do anything social. I just basically went to work, just like everybody. I went to work. Everybody was tested every day. I went home.
我当时生活在那种环境中，就像所有人一样，我在吸收所有这些恶毒的言论，但我没有把它套用在自己身上。事实上，甚至当我开始做新闻秘书这份工作时，你知道，因为那是新冠疫情最严重的时候，我哪里都没去。我没有任何社交活动。我基本上就是去上班，就像所有人一样。我去上班。每个人每天都要做检测。我回家。
And it wasn't until maybe three or four months in, I was, I threw out the first pitch at a Nats game, which was amazing, but also I'd never found baseball before. No, I didn't do it. No, I didn't. I didn't. I would totally.
直到大概三四个月后，我在国民队（Nats）的一场比赛中投了第一球，这太棒了，但我也从来没有接触过棒球。不，我没做过。不，我没做。我绝对……
I was really in the leading up to it. I thought to myself, OK, Anthony Fauci and other people really did not do a good job. And if that happened, I was already playing for it in my head, but I would say about my failed pitch. But when I was there, which was kind of the first random social thing I did, my husband was just me. And this older man, I mean, it doesn't matter,
在事情发生前，我心里想的是，好吧，安东尼·福奇和其他人真的没有做好工作。如果发生那种事，我已经在心里做好心理准备了，但我会说我那糟糕的投球。但当我在那里时，那可以说是我做的第一件随意的社交事情，我的丈夫就在我身边。然后这个老年人，我的意思是，这不重要，
but just a description of him, was following me around going, shame, shame, shame. And it was like, what? What? So I know, because he didn't like Joe Biden, maybe he didn't like the policies of the world I stood for. It's true. Who knows?
但只是对他的一段描述，一直跟着我喊，耻辱，耻辱，耻辱。当时我就想，什么？什么？所以我知道，因为他不喜欢乔·拜登，也许他不喜欢我所代表的世界的政策。确实如此。谁知道呢？
But to answer your question, now I'm giving you a long answer. I didn't really digest it in that way. And it really, but experiencing it and living it. And this happens to certainly people of both parties. So, but what I think has happened in more recent years is anyone who, and I don't know how it is for all of you, do people hate you in a different way?
但回答你的问题，现在我给你的回答很长。我当时并没有真正以那种方式去消化它。而真正去体验它、经历它。这当然会发生在两党的人身上。所以，但我认为近年来发生的事情是，任何，我不知道你们所有人都是这样的吗，人们是以一种不同的方式讨厌你吗？
Or do they just all love the way? How does it work? There's three categories. I just heard the three. Mostly to Sean, go ahead. Yeah. He gives a lot. I mean, Sean's answer on happiness.
还是他们只是都喜欢这种方式？这到底是怎么运作的？有三个类别。我刚听到这三个。主要针对肖恩，请说。是的。他提供了很多。我的意思是，肖恩关于幸福的回答。
I feel like, how could you not love him? I feel outraged about this. There's people who can't continue. There's three groups of people for you, for us, for anybody that's in the public eye. The people who hate you will always hate you. The people who love you will always, oh no, no. It's no matter what you do, The people who hate you will always hate you. The people who love you will always, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
我觉得，你怎么能不爱他呢？我对此感到愤怒。有些人无法继续。对你、对我们、对任何身处公众视线的人来说，有三类人。恨你的人永远都会恨你。爱你的人永远都会，哦不，不。无论你做什么，恨你的人永远都会恨你。爱你的人永远都会，哦不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，
no matter what you do, the people who hate you will always hate you, no matter what you do, the people who love you will always love you, and no matter what you do, the people who don't care about you don't care about you are indifferent. Those are the three groups, right? Yeah, you're not, you're not turning anybody. There's not gonna be anybody. You didn't get a lot of letters going,
无论你做什么，恨你的人永远都会恨你，无论你做什么，爱你的人永远都会爱你，无论你做什么，不在乎你的人就是不在乎你，他们是冷漠的。就是这三类人，对吧？是的，你没法，你没法改变任何人。不会有任何人的。你没有收到很多信说，
hey, you know, I really hated you a lot for the first three years. And you know what? You said, yeah, I was I'm just wrong about it. Like, it just doesn't exist in that way, which is absurd. Yeah. And we will be right back. Swantles is brought to you in part by all birds. Now, I do like shoes.
嘿，你知道，前三年我真的很讨厌你。你知道吗？你说了，对，我在这方面确实错了。这根本不存在，太荒谬了。是的。我们马上回来。SmartLess 的部分赞助商是 Allbirds。现在，我确实喜欢鞋子。
I'm not like a shoe freak or a sneaker head, but you know, I'm not opposed to a nice snappy set of shoes that can really put the nice accent on a frickin' choice of outfit I slapped together. So all birds sometimes will do that for me, you know, not because they're flashy, but because they're not. You know what I mean? If you're looking to elevate your style,
我不是那种鞋迷或运动鞋狂热分子，但我并不排斥一双漂亮的鞋子，它真的能为我拼凑出的那一套该死的衣服增添漂亮的亮点。所以 Allbirds 有时候会为我做到这一点，你知道，不是因为它们花哨，而是因为它们不花哨。你知道我的意思吗？如果你想提升你的风格，
I want you to check out all birds, all new career classic. The all new career is a natural classic that keeps up with each step you take throughout the day and night. So you can look good while you're doing good or bad. I added that. The clean retro silhouette keeps things casual while the intricate details give this
我希望你来看看 Allbirds 全新的 Tree Lounger 休闲鞋。全新的 Tree Lounger 是一款经典天然休闲鞋，能跟上你白天和黑夜迈出的每一步，让你在做好事或做坏事时都能看起来很帅。这句是我加的。干净的复古剪裁让它保持休闲，而精致的细节则赋予了这款
sneaker enough oomph to wear out and about. All birds makes the most out of sustainable materials like leather made from plants, sugarcane and tree fibers. Materials so natural, one might even say they're supernatural and speaking of supernatural like a hero, Sean's here. Sean? Hey guys, yeah, I got a pair of tree dashers and they're blue and they're white on the bottom and I wear them every single day.
运动鞋足够的活力，适合外出时穿着。Allbirds 充分利用了可持续材料，比如植物皮革、甘蔗和树木纤维。这些材料如此天然，甚至有人会说它们是超自然的。说到像英雄一样的超自然，肖恩来了。肖恩？嘿，大家好，对，我有一双 Tree Dashers，它们是蓝色的，底是白色的，我每天都穿。
And that is a true story because they're so comfortable I wear them to the theater every day. I also got a pair, very comfy, very good looking kind of like my pod mate, Sean P. Hayes. Every day comfort delivered. All birds all new career. Elevate your supernatural style at allbirds.com today and use code SmartLess for free socks with your purchase. That's a double L-B-I-R-D-S dot com code smartless.
这是一个真实的故事，因为它们太舒服了，我每天去剧院都穿。我也有一双，非常舒服，非常好看，就像我的播客搭档肖恩·P·海斯一样。每天都享受舒适。Allbirds 全新 Tree Lounger。今天就登录 allbirds.com 提升你的超自然风格，并在购买时使用代码 SmartLess 获取免费袜子。网址是双 L-B-I-R-D-S 点 com，代码是 smartless。
Smartless listeners, we are supported by Fandool. Snap into action this NFL season with Fandool. America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's $200 in bonus bets win or lose. If you've been thinking about joining Fandool, there's no better time to get in on the action. The app's easy to use.
SmartLess 的听众们，我们得到了 FanDuel 的支持。在这个 NFL 赛季，用 FanDuel 开启你的行动，这是全美第一的体育博彩公司。现在，新客户在下注 5 美元时即可保证获得 200 美元的奖金投注。无论输赢，都有 200 美元的奖金投注。如果你一直在考虑加入 FanDuel，现在正是加入的最佳时机。这款 App 易于使用，
There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads, player props, overunders, and more. I have a friend that uses Fandool, raves about it, actually has one money on it and then shoves it in my face. Like, look at me, I'm so awesome, I use Fandool. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season.
提供广泛的投注选择，包括让分盘、球员道具、大小盘等。我有一个朋友用 FanDuel，对它赞不绝口，实际上还在上面赢了钱，然后在我面前炫耀。就像，看我，我太棒了，我用 FanDuel。所以请访问 fandool.com/smartless 并开启 NFL 赛季。
Fandool, official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. One of the things that, I think, Will, you've made fun of me for when I talk about getting getting news when you're in the White House versus getting like, I like it. Jason, think that there's a secret news.
FanDuel 是 NFL 的官方合作伙伴，21 岁及以上，限制适用。请参阅节目说明了解完整的免责声明。现在回到节目中。威尔，你以前取笑过我的一件事，当我谈到在白宫获取新闻与获取新闻的区别时，我挺喜欢的。杰森，你觉得有一个秘密新闻。
I've heard you talk about this. Well, you think there's a secret source of information, right? No, there's a secret, but I think there's a news source for the news people. But I think you get information inside the White House earlier than say the press gets it. And I'd not buy a lot, but maybe by a few minutes, maybe an hour at times, yes. Yes.
我听你谈过这个。嗯，你认为存在一个秘密的信息来源，对吧？不，没有秘密，但我认为新闻界确实有一个新闻来源。但我认为你在白宫内部获取信息的时间比新闻界要早。而且不是早很多，但也许早几分钟，有时候甚至早一个小时，是的。是的。
Well, not exactly. Although, I do think you're onto a little bit of something is that you are making a bunch of the news in the White House, right? So in that sense, yes. I mean, if you're sitting, which I did, and many others did many times, in the situation room, and you know that something is going to happen, you're going to reopen
嗯，不完全是。不过，我确实认为你说得有点道理，那就是你在白宫里创造了许多新闻，对吧？所以在某种意义上，是的。我的意思是，如果你坐在——我做过，许多其他人也多次这样做过——situation room（战情室）里，而且你知道将要发生某事，你要重新建立
relations with Cuba. Whatever you're going to do, you're going to go after that. Or you're going to incoming from the defense department saying we have just, we've just gotten rid of one of the ISIS leaders or whatever. You guys get that information before the, so now. Then you know it's coming, yes. Right, but now that you're in the media, do you wish that you still had some of those same choices or avenues? Of course, yes. I mean, it's, you know, what do I mean?
与古巴的关系。无论你要做什么，你都会去追究。或者国防部会传来消息说，我们刚刚，我们刚刚除掉了ISIS的头目之一什么的。你们在这些消息传出之前就能得到信息，所以现在。然后你就知道它要来了，是的。对，但是现在你身处媒体界，你是否希望自己依然拥有当初的某些选择或途径？当然，是的。我的意思是，你知道，我是什么意思？
I love my job, I love doing a TV show, I get to talk about all sorts of different things and talk to all sorts of smart people here. But I do miss being able to just walk into Jake Sullivan's office or even the OO office and just say, what's the deal with this? And there's certainly been news that's happened that you think, what is the deal with this? I want to know what the deal is.
我热爱我的工作，我喜欢做电视节目，在这里我可以谈论各种不同的事情，和各种聪明人交流。但我确实怀念那种可以直接走入杰克·沙利文（Jake Sullivan）办公室，甚至是椭圆形办公室，然后问一句“这到底是怎么回事？”的日子。而且肯定也发生过一些新闻，让你觉得，这到底是怎么回事？我很想知道真相是什么。
It doesn't mean that. Yeah, it's like with airline food, right? Like what's the deal? There's sources as a journalist. Like does that ever... A bit, your sources as a journalist are incredible, right? Like what's it? Like your sources as a journalist like does that ever bet your sources as a journalist are incredible, right? Because you've got many, many high, high level friends in the government still. Yeah, look, I mean, I think Jen Jen, Jen, sorry, I hate to interrupt you. I just want to make sure
并不是那个意思。是的，就像飞机上的餐食一样，对吧？就像是怎么回事？作为记者，你有消息源。这会不会……有一点，你作为记者的消息源太不可思议了，对吧？就像是怎样的？你作为记者的消息源怎么会……这会不会让你作为记者的消息源显得不可思议，对吧？因为你在政府里依然有很多很多高层朋友。是的，听着，我的意思是，我觉得詹，詹，詹，对不起，我不想打断你。我只是想确保
it's got a okay, because I know he just got back from the gym and I can see him in the background is. Yeah. Is it cool enough? Do you need to? Are you okay from the gym? I said you like the air conditioning on when you come back. Are you? Yeah. All right. Okay. Because you got the blanket stuff.
没问题，因为我知道他刚从健身房回来，我能看到他在背景里。是的。够酷吗？你需要吗？你从健身房回来没事吧？我说过你回来时喜欢开着空调。是吗？好吧。没问题。因为你拿了毛毯之类的东西。
I'm so sorry. I mean it's all good. It's all good. I can hear Joy Reed who I know has been on before. I can hear in the hallway. She's three doors out. No, she's literally walking by my own. You're work right now.
真的很抱歉。我是说一切都好。一切都好。我能听到乔·里德（Joy Reed）的声音，我知道她以前来过。我能在走廊里听到她的声音。她就在三扇门外。不，她 literalmente（字面意思）正走过我的办公室。你现在在工作。
Hell her. Yeah. That's so bad. That's so bad. She's not a phone. Yeah. So where is that Washington or New York? Yeah. Washington. Oh, God.
跟她打招呼。是的。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。她没有手机。是的。所以那是华盛顿还是纽约？是的。华盛顿。哦，天哪。
I would dork out so much in those offices. Just come on down. Joy and I will take you around. We can take you on the meat, the press site. Just can be so nerdy and amazing. It would be so good. So now, Jen, I have something to say before I want to get into how you started because now since we're talking
我在那些办公室里会表现得像个书呆子。下来吧。乔和我带你四处看看。我们可以带你参观媒体区。真的可以变得非常书呆子气而且太棒了。那会非常棒。那么，詹，在我探讨你是如何开始之前，我有些话要说，因为既然我们正在谈论
about the White House press room and everything like that. Now watching from home, first of all, you're on because you were also on Jason's list, I think, because we love you, we admire you. I love you and your brain. I'm in the neutral. Yes, and whenever you would come. You were on my list too.
白宫新闻发布室以及诸如此类的事情。现在在家看电视，首先，你能上节目是因为你也在杰森的名单上，我想，因为我们爱你，我们崇拜你。我爱你的大脑。我在中立立场。是的，无论你什么时候来。你也在我的名单上。
It's cool, it's cool. It's cool, it's cool. It's fine. Now you know. No, you were on my list. I know the two who have had sex. Why don't you run, you You were on my list too. It's cool, it's cool. It's fine. Now you know. But it's okay. I know the two who have had sex. Why don't you run three of my list? I run that's much more of a taper. No, you were in my list.
太酷了，太酷了。太酷了，太酷了。没关系。现在你知道了。不，你在我的名单上。我知道那两个有过性关系的人。你为什么不跑……你也在我的名单上。太酷了，太酷了。没关系。现在你知道了。但没关系。我知道那两个有过性关系的人。你为什么不把我名单上的三个人跑一遍？我跑那个更像是个锥形。不，你在我的名单上。
Yeah, it loves the old tap. I would shake taper. He writes some good fiction books. It's all good. We love it. You run three of my list. You run three of my list. Three of my list.
是的，非常喜欢那个老锥形。我会摇晃锥形。他写了一些不错的小说。一切都好。我们喜欢它。你跑了我名单上的三个人。你跑了我名单上的三个人。我名单上的三个人。
Two things. At the end of the question, I want to know what the hell's in the binder. I think everyone wants to know what's in the binder, because it's so thick and you flip through it, and I want to know. A lot. What if it was just menus or something?
两件事。在问题结束时，我想知道那个活页夹里到底是什么鬼东西。我想每个人都想知道活页夹里有什么，因为它太厚了，你翻来翻去，我想知道。很多。如果里面只是菜单或者别的什么呢？
I just did it to spare me. It looks like. It looks like. I think I'll have the fried rice with the... Whenever you would come out to speak at a press conference, I'd be watching on TV, and be like, I'd point to the TV, I'm like, yeah, what Jen said. Like, I don't have the gift like you do
我这么做只是为了放过我自己。它看起来像。它看起来像。我想我会点一份炒饭配……每当你要出来开新闻发布会时，我在电视上看着，就会像这样，指着电视说，对，就是詹说的。就像，我没有你那种
of just generally articulation and speaking in a succinct manner. And you always made the best point. You gave the most clarity when explaining a position on a certain topical issue. And you have the gift of communicating in a way that makes a digestible to us, right? Thank you.
那种清晰的表达能力，以及以简明扼要的方式说话的能力。你总是能切中要害。在解释某个时事话题的立场时，你表达得最为清晰。你有一种沟通的天赋，能以一种让我们容易理解的方式表达，对吧？谢谢你。
And always, at least to me, there was always such common sense to everything you said. Sounds like a butt. I say that because it's okay, there's a butt. There's a butt coming or something. Well, I'm asking because, like you said, for debate, because now it seems the whole thing, it's an interesting job as press secretary, whether it's Democratic president or Republican president or whatever. And there's never going to be a situation where the press secretary goes, you know what? Great question. You got me. There's always going to be this thing where you know what
而且总是，至少对我和我而言，你所说的一切都充满了常识。听起来像是有个“但是”。我这么说是因为，好吧，确实有个“但是”。有一个“但是”要来，或者别的什么。好吧，我这么问是因为，正如你所说，关于辩论，因为现在看起来整件事，作为新闻秘书是一份有趣的工作，无论是民主党总统还是共和党总统什么的。而且永远不会出现这样一种情况：新闻秘书会说，你知道吗？问得好。你难住我了。总会有这样一种情况：你知道
they're going to ask and they know you prepared the questions. So what's going on here? Well, that's true. I mean, look, the truth is, I think so. I mean, Fox News, I called on them every day. They didn't exactly like the Biden administration as a network.
他们会问什么，他们也知道你准备好了问题。所以这到底是怎么回事？嗯，这是真的。我是说，听着，事实是，我想是的。我是说，福克斯新闻，我每天都点他们。作为一个电视网，他们并不是特别喜欢拜登政府。
They were really predictable because if you watch Fox on them every day, they didn't exactly like the Biden administration as a network. They were really predictable because if you watch Fox News every day, they kind of had a rotation of at the time when I was there. The border is burning and hundreds of thousands of people are coming across the border. COVID is a disaster and there's a rotation of things. So somewhat predictable is going to be one of those questions. Sure. Did we get an update on the caravan? Did it ever make it? Because man, there were a lot of... It's really hard to make it if something is a fabrication. That is true. I had a friend, I had a friend who's like these guys.
他们真的很可预测，如果你每天都看福克斯新闻，他们……我每天都点他们，他们并不是特别喜欢拜登政府。他们真的很可预测，如果你每天都看福克斯新闻，我在那里的时候，他们基本上有一种轮流轰炸的主题。边境正在燃烧，成千上万的人正在越过边境。新冠是一场灾难，有各种轮流轰炸的话题。所以稍微可以预测会有其中一个问题。当然。我们有大篷车（移民队伍）的最新消息吗？它真的成功到达了吗？因为天哪，有那么多……如果某事是捏造的，那就很难实现。确实如此。我有个朋友，我有个朋友就像这些家伙一样。
Who was in the caravan? Yeah. Is he a good friend? He was staying with you now. He was a friend. I'm not going to name him comedian sort of older guy a little bit like a little bit older than we are And he got he's one of those people who made that turn into Fox News when he got to be about 60 And it's a real bummer and I see him in boblot and he's like and his whole thing was the caravan
谁在大篷车里？是的。他是好朋友吗？他现在和你住在一起。他是个朋友。我不会说出他的名字，是个喜剧演员，稍微年长一点的家伙，比我们大一点。他就是那种当他大约60岁时开始转而看福克斯新闻的人。这真的很令人沮丧，我在鲍勃洛特看到他，他就像是，他整个人都在谈论大篷车
I'm like man, I it's not real. I mean go ahead anyway. Sorry. Yeah, well because you're often in a situation where you're up there Anyway, sorry. Yeah, well, because you're often in a situation where you're up there presenting facts, right? You're sitting there in the hub of information what is real what is not from an international level to a domestic level right and yet they're sitting there hearing you relay that Generally and then they say yeah, no, I don't believe Or that, like, I don't know where you go from there. Well, I think you try to make a dent into it. I mean, you're not, you try to present the counter story or the counter of the facts into counter
我说，老兄，这不是真的。我是说，不管怎样，继续吧。抱歉。是的，好吧，因为你经常处于那种你在上面……不管怎样，继续吧。抱歉。是的，好吧，因为你经常处于那种你在上面陈述事实的处境，对吧？你坐在信息中心，从国际层面到国内层面，什么是真的，什么是假的，对吧？然而他们坐在那里听你转述这些普遍情况，然后他们说，不，我不相信。或者说，我不知道从那以后你还能去哪。嗯，我觉得你是试图打破这个僵局。我是说，你不是，你试图提出相反的故事或相反的事实来反驳
what the accusation is. But does that feel like drop in the bucket? Does it feel deflating? Do you feel defeated sometimes? Not really. I mean, the days that were defeating were the days where you'd answer the same question 50 times. Right. And those, there were days like that. That's okay. I mean, the truth is the facts, questions were not the hardest ones. They're not the hardest ones in there. The hardest ones are the people who are the experienced in-depth print reporters who are gonna actually ask you the very hard question that's hard to answer
这些指控。但这感觉像是杯水车薪吗？这感觉令人泄气吗？你有时会觉得被打败了吗？其实并没有。我是说，让人感到挫败的日子是那些你需要把同一个问题回答50遍的日子。对。而且那些，确实有过那样的日子。没关系。我是说，事实是，事实类的问题并不是最难的。它们不是里面最难的。最难的是那些经验丰富、深入基层的印刷媒体记者，他们会真正问你那些很难回答的极其尖锐的问题
because they've been working on it. That you may not expect. That you may not expect or you may see them in the room and you say, oh shit, I need to like warm up before I get to that person. Because the point of my question was or comment was just the fact that, and Jay, I know you said you didn't get it, but what I was trying to say was,
因为他们一直在为此努力。这是你可能意想不到的。这是你可能意想不到的，或者你会在房间里看到他们，然后你会想，哦，该死，我在接近那个人之前得热身一下。因为我提问的重点或评论的重点仅仅在于，杰伊，我知道你说你没懂，但我想表达的是，
it's not that surprising the questions you know that you're going to get that day. Sure. Right? So, you're part of the job is to prepare for these things that are the issues of the day. Yeah, that's right. And there's a significant prep before you go out there, yes? I mean, that's why sometimes you guys are delayed, right? Because you're going to sit there with the man and say, what should our response be on
你那天会遇到的问题其实并不让人意外。当然。对吧？所以，你的部分工作就是为这些当天的热点问题做好准备。对，没错。在你走上台前，有大量的准备工作，对吗？我的意思是，这就是为什么有时你们会迟到，对吧？因为你要坐在那个人身边说，我们对
X, Y, or Z? Yeah, sometimes in exactly the man. I love it. I think he'd like to, you're talking about your Biden, he'd like to refer to that way. Dark Brandon, the man, the guy, the evil, whatever. Exactly. Well, look, I mean, I think when I was in the job,
X、Y 或 Z 应该有什么回应？对，有时候正好就是那个人。我太喜欢了。我想他会愿意，你指的是你的拜登，他会喜欢被那样称呼。黑化布兰登，那个人，那个家伙，那个恶魔，诸如此类。没错。好吧，你看，我的意思是，我认为当我在那个岗位时，
and I think anyone who's done that job sees their job as, is speaking, of course, on behalf of the president. So you have to get feedback from that person to make sure you are projecting what they think, what their point of view is, what's actually going on. And sometimes, you know, the job, when I was doing it, I always felt like it was just, you wanna push as hard as you can push
而且我认为任何做过那个工作的人都认为他们的工作是，当然是代表总统发言。所以你必须从那个人那里获得反馈，以确保你传达的是他们的想法，他们的观点，以及实际发生的事情。有时候，你知道，这份工作，当我做的时候，我总是觉得它只是，你想尽你所能去推动
on the system internally, whether it's the policy experts or the president or others to say, we need more, we need more, we need to be able to say more because you're kind of the bridge between the media, the press, and the president, and the senior members of the team. So, yeah, sometimes it was delayed because of that. Is there a specific moment or question or any kind of thing that really sticks in your memory where you're super, super close to saying, why don't you go fuck yourself? your memory where you're super, super close to saying, why don't you go fuck yourself? Oh.
系统内部的发展，无论是政策专家、总统还是其他人，并说我们需要更多，我们需要更多，我们需要能够说更多，因为你有点像媒体、新闻界与总统以及团队高级成员之间的桥梁。所以，是的，有时因为这个原因会延误。有没有哪个具体的时刻、问题或者任何真正留在你记忆深中的事情，让你超级、超级接近说出“你怎么不滚去吃屎呢？”你在记忆深处有那种超级、超级接近说出“你怎么不滚去吃屎呢？”的时刻吗？哦。
The people who know me well would say that, like, there were times where I basically did without saying, go fuck yourself. Right, yeah. So, yes, of course. I mean, there were certainly moments where I lost kind of my steam when it was the 11th or 12th time of a question being asked and you just sort of,
了解我的人会说，就像，有些时候我基本上没说出口，但心里就是“滚去吃屎吧”。对，没错。所以，是的，当然。我的意思是，肯定有那么几个时刻，当一个问题被问到第 11 或第 12 次时，我的耐心耗尽了，然后你就会有点，
but then what happens is that portion where you lose your steam or you don't give the full answer or you lose your temper is what goes online, right? So can we wear that? Exactly. There was a particular, I don't remember who he's worked for, but he asked me about abortion all the time and there was a time where basically ripped his head off. So, you know, there are times because you're human. I'm an Irish lass in my heart. I can't be level headed at all moments, but, you know, you tried to, especially given the time that we are in and we were in two years ago,
但接下来发生的是，你失去耐心、没有给出完整答案或发脾气的那个片段会被发到网上，对吧？所以我们能对此负责吗？完全可以。有一次，我不记得他为谁工作了，但他一直问我关于堕胎的问题，有一次我基本上把他的头都撕下来了。所以，你知道，有时会这样，因为你是人。我内心是个爱尔兰姑娘。我不可能在所有时刻都保持头脑冷静，但是，你知道，你努力去保持冷静，特别是考虑到我们所处的时代以及我们两年前所处的时代，
the whole goal was to try to be calm and even keeled because we needed to kind of take the venom out of the briefing room and return it to a place that was providing information to the public. And is the official angle that you're speaking on behalf of the president or you're speaking on behalf of the United States? Because there's a difference there, right? That is true. That's a good question. Thank you. But kind of bull. As did you get that? Did you hear it? Stop. It's a big one. We're recording. Guys, did you get that? Did you hear all the cheers? It's a big one.
整个目标就是尽量保持冷静和沉着，因为我们需要化解发布会现场的火药味，让它回归一个为公众提供信息的场所。那么官方的立场是，你是代表总统发言，还是代表美国发言？因为这两者之间是有区别的，对吧？确实如此。这是一个好问题。谢谢。但有点废话。你听到了吗？听到了吗？停。这是个大事。我们在录音呢。伙计们，你们听到了吗？听到所有的欢呼声了吗？这是个大事。
We're recording. Where do you think his nickname is Stopped Clock? Yes. No, it's kind of the answer is both, because sometimes the questions were about the president's view. He is the leader of the United States or the president's meetings or his schedule or his conversation. And then there were sometimes questions about the policy of the United States. Which are sometimes that odd. I was going to say things that were at odds with the
我们在录音呢。你觉得他的绰号为什么叫“停摆的钟”？对。不，答案是两者皆有，因为有时问题是关于总统的观点的。他是美国的领导人，或者是关于总统的会议、日程安排或对话。有时也会有关于美国政策的问题。而这些有时候很奇怪。我是说那些与
policy of the United States. That's when things got a little tricky. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-aki. You were born in Stanford, Connecticut. Is that a punishment? Well, I was born in New York City. Oh, I thought you were born in Stanford. It's all good. They're close by. When did you move to Stanford? I mean, I was my parents were living there when I was born, but I was born in New York City hospital.
美国政策相左的事情。那就是事情变得有点棘手的时候。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯. 你出生在康涅狄格州斯坦福。那是一种惩罚吗？嗯，我出生在纽约市。哦，我以为你出生在斯坦福。没关系。它们离得很近。你什么时候搬到斯坦福的？我的意思是，我出生时我父母就住在那里，但我是在纽约市的一家医院出生的。
Okay. So you're arguing. Well, now you're arguing. Refresh your Wikipedia page. Yeah, I don't know. I'm also not Polish. Not that there's anything wrong with that. Not Polish? No. Not Polish. That's on your wiki page to no
好吧。所以你在争辩。好吧，现在你在争辩了。刷新一下你的维基百科页面吧。好吧，我不知道。我也不是波兰人。倒不是说这有什么不对。不是波兰人？不。不是波兰人。那在你的维基页面上
I didn't say Polish. I didn't know. Maybe it's not on there anymore. I'm not are you Greek and Irish? What else? What are you? I am Greek and Irish Greek and Irish. Yeah, you're Gryresh. I never heard that but I like that What about your so you've three sisters you older oldest of three sisters your mom was a therapist. Yeah, still is. Still is. What was that like? Oh, she still is. I love that. I could use her. What was that like growing up and did that kind of, um, you know, because therapists are very smart people. Yeah. Is it to teach you to communicate better? Oh, maybe. I mean, my mother didn't go to college until after I was born. And she didn't become a therapist until I was probably about nine or ten and she
我没说我是波兰人。我不知道。也许它已经不在上面了。我不是，你是希腊和爱尔兰血统吗？还有什么？你是什么血统？我是希腊和爱尔兰血统。希腊和爱尔兰。对，你是“希爱混血”。我从没听说过这个词，但我挺喜欢。那你，你有三个姐妹，你是三姐妹里老大，你妈妈是个治疗师。对，现在还是。现在还是。那是什么体验？哦，她现在还是。我真喜欢。我真需要她。在那种环境下长大是什么感觉，这有没有，嗯，你知道的，因为治疗师是非常聪明的人。对。这有没有教你更好地沟通？哦，也许吧。我的意思是，我母亲直到我出生后才上大学。直到我大概九、十岁时她才成为一名治疗师，而且她
used to have appointments in our house at night sometimes after we went to bed or later but she always it never really she was always around which was great for me as a kid and she was obviously doing school and stuff but she still is like a this great advice giver I mean mean, as a mom, she's somebody I call, and I think, what should I do about this? That is pretty good. She biased a little bit. So did she masquerade the therapy as parenting?
有时晚上等我们上床睡觉后或更晚的时候，会在家里接待预约客户，但她总是，这其实从没，她总是陪在我们身边，这对我小时候来说太棒了，虽然她当时还要上学之类的，但她现在依然是一个能给出极好建议的人。我的意思是，作为妈妈，她是那种我会打电话过去，然后心想，“我该怎么处理这件事？”的人。那真的很不错。她有点偏心。那么她有没有把心理治疗伪装成育儿？
Ever, you know what I mean? Like did she mix the two? Yeah, she did. Although my sister and I still, my sister's two years, one of them's two years younger than me. And we still laugh about this timing. And my mom, you know, did therapy for families, troubled sisters, one of them's two years younger than me. And we still laugh about this timing. My mom did therapy for families, troubled teens, their parents.
你懂我的意思吗？比如她有没有把这两者混为一谈？对，她确实混过。虽然我和我妹妹——我妹妹比我小两岁，其中一个比我小两岁——我们现在还会拿这个时间差开玩笑。我妈妈，你知道的，为家庭、有问题的小姐妹做心理治疗，其中一个比我小两岁。我们现在还会拿这个时间差开玩笑。我妈妈为家庭、问题青少年和他们的父母做心理治疗。
And when we were in high school, we came home from high school one day, and my mother said, what is this? What is this? And she was holding something up. And she thought we were like, vacated into drugs or something or doing tons of drugs. And I was like, mom, it's the drawstring to my shorts. She has no, even though she dealt with adolescents and all sorts of drugs. And I was like, Mom, it's the drawstring to my shorts. She has no, even though she dealt with adolescents
有一次我们在高中放学回家，我妈妈说，这是什么？这是什么？她举起某样东西。她以为我们吸毒了还是怎么的，或者嗑了很多药。我说，妈妈，这是我短裤上的抽绳。她完全没有，尽管她接触过青少年和各种各样的毒品，但我还是说，妈妈，这是我短裤上的抽绳。她完全没有，尽管她接触过青少年
and all sorts of things, she really was also kind of a, had a little blind spot around that sort of thing. So it was dad around? Dad was around too, yep. My dad worked in New York. Good for you and Irish dad, that's dead. Irish and Greek, Irish in Greek. Yeah, my dad is still is, I mean, he's 80 now,
和各种各样的事情，但在那种事情上她真的也有点盲区。那爸爸在吗？爸爸也在，对。我爸爸在纽约工作。真不错，还有个爱尔兰老爸，那是老爸。爱尔兰和希腊血统，爱尔兰和希腊。对，我爸爸现在依然是，我的意思是，他现在80岁了，
but when I was growing up, it was like family vacations where he knocked on your door at 6 a.m. and you went out for a, you know, four hour bike ride and then a six hour canoe and then that was, maybe you could rest after that. There's an intensity. The shine's dead shine stat was 80.
但当我长大时，就像家庭度假一样，他会在早上6点敲你的门，然后你出去进行一次，你知道的，四小时的自行车骑行，然后是六小时的独木舟，在那之后，也许你才能休息。那真是太有强度了。老爸现在80岁了。
Sorry, he was going 80. What are you going in? I'm not. Yeah, go screw yourself, man. Oh, and then I just had the black exhaust on my face. Shine stat up to when he was a kid. And it's been a source of a lot of laughs. One lot of life.
抱歉，他已经80岁了。你在干嘛？我没有。是的，去你的吧，老兄。哦，然后我脸上就吃了一股黑烟。老爸一直保持到他当孩子的时候。这成了许多笑料的源泉。一生的笑料。
So it was. And then, Jen, you married Greg. Yeah. Right? Sweet Greg. Sweet Greg. Sweet Greg. Chief of Staff to Congressman Joe Kennedy.
确实如此。然后，珍，你嫁给了格格。对吧？可爱的格格。可爱的格格。可爱的格格。国会议员乔·肯尼迪的幕僚长。
He was. And where did you two meet? And do you, same question about your mom now to you and your husband, Greg, and your kids? Do you know, is there debate that goes on in the house in a way that you, you know, because of your background? Oh, between us about politics. Yeah. Sometimes, I mean, we met at the Democratic Congressional Campaign Committee, which is a very DC,
他曾是。你们两个是在哪里认识的？对于你、你丈夫格格还有你们的孩子，我用问你妈妈时同样的问题问你：你知道吗，由于你的背景，你们家里会不会经常有那种，你知道的，激烈的辩论？哦，关于政治，我们之间吗？对。有时候，我的意思是，我们在民主党国会竞选委员会认识的，那是一个非常华盛顿、
nerdy, sir, hot, exactly. A hot AF, keep a little around. Exactly. He brought me some graders ice cream, if anybody knows of graders since then. Yes. What? Have it in my place right now. Best ice cream on the planet, okay.
书呆子气、性感，确实如此。性感得要命，一直萦绕在心。没错。他给我带了格雷泽冰淇淋，如果有人从那时候起就知道格雷泽的话。对。什么？我家里现在就有一盒。星球上最好的冰淇淋，好吧。
Yeah, it was, that's where it all started. Rama manual takes credit for us getting together. So that's funny, because Greg traveled with him. But yeah, we dated long distance for a couple of years, you know, all the things, but still, Mary, Mary 13, how long have you married? 13 years, 13 years. Wow, that's great. And how old are your kids?
对，就是那样，一切就是从那里开始的。伊曼纽尔把我们撮合到一起记作他的功劳。所以这很有趣，因为格格曾跟他一起出差。不过，是的，我们异地恋了好几年，你知道的，经历了所有那些事，但依然，结婚，结婚13年了，你们结婚多久了？13年，13年。哇，那太棒了。孩子们多大了？
They are five and almost eight. Eight on Thursday. Wow. Oh my God. And you took your daughter to the Taylor Swift concert. I saw her in the screen. I did. I did.
他们一个五岁，快八岁了。周四就满八岁了。哇。哦，天哪。你带你女儿去看了泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会。我在屏幕上看到了。是的，我去了。
She was at the greatest thing ever. I'm about to do the same thing. Oh, she's a great show. I should know that. I've got a 16 and an 11, two girls. And did they know they're going? Yeah, yeah, and they're fired up. And I'm kind of fired up.
那是史上最棒的事情。我也正打算去呢。哦，她的演出太棒了。我应该知道的。我有两个女儿，一个16岁，一个11岁。她们知道自己要去吗？对，对，她们兴奋极了。我也挺兴奋的。
We've got a mutual friend, Willie, that said that it's the greatest concert he's ever been to. And he's our age. So he's been to a lot of shows and been to a lot of great shows. And I don't think he was exaggerating well, right? I mean, that sounded pretty sincere. And so I'm really looking forward to seeing him. Oh, yeah, yeah, he loved it. Yeah, loved it. And when you say fired
我们有个共同的朋友威利，他说那是他看过的最棒的演唱会。而且他跟我们同龄。所以他看过很多演出，也看过很多精彩的演出。我觉得他绝对没有夸张，对吧？我的意思是，听起来挺真诚的。所以我真的很期待去看。哦，对，对，他超爱。是的，超爱。当你用“兴奋”
up, Jay, you mean you're firing up the chopper to land it so far because you don't like to deal with traffic. I'm not too much. I'm just going to hover actually. I'm going to lower the kids down, but I'm going to stay up. Oh, there it is. Oh, boy. Oh, yeah, we're holding up ice cream to the camera. It's so good. It's really good. I love it. Sean, by the way, we got a pineapple ice cream in the house. Yeah, I'm so sorry. If you looked in Sean's freezer, you'd see He's like ice cream from Ohio. We got ice cream from Indiana. We got ice cream from every state. It's okay. I think he's a greater fan. So there you go. I feel like I like it. Jan, what's going on with the Hollywood correspondence or not Hollywood course? What's it called?
这个词时，杰伊，你是说你要开着直升机降落，因为你讨厌处理交通堵塞吗？我没那么夸张。其实我打算悬停。我会把孩子们放下去，但我自己留在上面。哦，来了。哦，天哪。哦，对了，我们在对着镜头举冰淇淋。太棒了。真的很好吃。我太喜欢了。肖恩，顺便说一句，我们屋里还有菠萝冰淇淋。是的，非常抱歉。如果你翻翻肖恩的冰箱，你会发现他有来自俄亥俄州的冰淇淋。我们有来自印第安纳州的冰淇淋。我们有来自各州的冰淇淋。没关系。我觉得他是格雷泽冰淇淋的粉丝。所以就是这样。我觉得我挺喜欢的。珍，好莱坞记者协会还是什么好莱坞记者——怎么称呼来着？
There's something correspondence center. Well, the White House correspondence center. The White House correspondence. That's right. Now, I went there once and I really, we were there. Right. Yeah. We loved it. But has it, has it taken, it's taken a hit lately, right? Well, probably because of the last administration, no one really wanted to go. But like, can we get that back up and running and make it kind of like... Make it cool again. Wait, does it not happen anymore?
有个什么记者中心。嗯，白宫记者协会。白宫记者协会。没错。好吧，我以前去过一次，我们真的去过。对。是的。我们很喜欢。但它，它最近受到打击了，对吧？嗯，可能是因为上一届政府，真的没人想去。但是，我们能把它重新搞起来，让它变得像以前那样吗？让它再次变得酷炫。等等，现在没有这个活动了吗？
I mean, it does, but I want to go back. I think it can come back. I mean, I'm going to put some responsibility down all of you because in order for it to be fun, you've got to bring fun people who are not political. Well, I want to invite us. You can... You're invited. You're invited. Do you all want to come with NBC and MSNBC next year? Yeah, of course we do it.
我的意思是，有的，但我希望它能恢复。我觉得它可以卷土重来。我的意思是，我要把一些责任推给在座的各位，因为要想让它变得有趣，你们得带一些有趣且非政治圈的人来。好吧，我想邀请我们。你可以……你被邀请了。你被邀请了。明年你们大家想跟 NBC 和 MSNBC 一起去吗？对，我们当然想去。
I'm going to come between two. Okay, let's do it. Yeah, what about the three of us will host it, right? Yeah, how about that? Oh, together. Oh, you'd be so good. Now, the White House Corresponds Association determine if they're going to ask you invite to speak,
我要坐在中间。好吧，我们就这么定吧。对，我们三个来主持怎么样？对，这样怎么样？哦，一起。哦，你们会配合得太好了。现在，白宫记者协会决定是否邀请你去发言，
but I can't. They're not going to. No, we're not going to ask them. You'd be good. There's better ones. They're do see family doesn't want us to do it. I can't. I can't even work with that. No, we're not gonna ask. You'd be good. There's better ones. We're not gonna. They do seem family doesn't want us to do it. No.
但我不能。他们不会的。不，我们不会去问的。你会表现得很好的。有更好的人选。华盛顿的家庭不想让我们去。我不能。我甚至无法应对这个。不，我们不会问。你会表现得很好的。有更好的人选。我们不会。华盛顿的家庭好像不想让我们去。不。
I will say one, I actually have a good relationship with Peter, do you see? But also, this year it was the most normal is not a good day to describe me because it's sort of a weird dinner. But people of all parties, different backgrounds, doing different things, all interacting. That's how it always used to be, and it kind of had a gap when it wasn't like that.
我要说的一点是，其实我和彼得关系很好，你知道的？而且，今年是最正常的一次——“正常”可能不是形容它的好词，因为它确实是一场挺奇特的晚宴。但来自各个政党、不同背景、从事不同行业的人都在一起交流。以前一直都是这样的，中间有一段时间不是这样的。
So this should have felt like that, which was kind of nice. And when is it traditionally? I forget. End of April. Or well, sometimes I think it's usually end of April. Okay. I want to know original aspirated career aspirations. Did you always, what were you in?
所以这次感觉又回到了那样，这挺不错的。传统上是在什么时候举办的？我忘了。四月底。或者，嗯，我想通常是在四月底。好吧。我想了解你最初的职业志向。你一直，你当时在想什么？
Jay, sorry, Sean. Jay, how many gummies before the White House correspondent? Oh, well, I'll be really fired up for that one. Oh, boy. Dude, I don't, I, I, this, I never leave the house with a gummy in my body. Okay.
杰伊，抱歉，肖恩。杰伊，在白宫记者晚宴之前你吃了多少软糖？哦，好吧，对那场晚宴我会超级兴奋的。哦，天哪。老兄，我不会，我，我，我离开家时绝对不会带一块软糖在身上。好吧。
Crazy. No, okay. And I don't have a freezer full of ice cream from every state. Yeah, and we're talking about vitamin gummies, right? We're two, yeah, of course. Of course, obviously. Abby, Sean. Sean.
太疯狂了。不，好吧。而且我也没有塞满各州冰淇淋的冰箱。对，我们说的是维生素软糖，对吧？我们俩，对，当然。当然，显而易见。艾比，肖恩。肖恩。
John. Original career aspirations, earliest memory, like the kind of career you wanted. Like, were this always your trajectory where you were like? No, I have never had a five-year plan. I certainly didn't when I was five. I still don't. So I did. I did. Um, remember 2020 with barber walkers and you know, I remember the music. And when I was a little kid, I just thought that show was great, which is kind of a weird thing. It's really exposing my nerdy side, which is
约翰。最初的职业志向，最早的记忆，比如你想要的职业类型。比如，你一直都是这种职业规划，就像你当时觉得……不，我从来没有过五年计划。我五岁时绝对没有。现在也没有。所以我有过。我有过。嗯，还记得芭芭拉·沃尔特斯的20/20节目吗，你知道的，我记得那个音乐。当我还是个小孩子的时候，我就觉得那个节目太棒了，这有点奇怪。这真的暴露了我书呆子的一面，
kind of obvious. But um, it was like more than just murder and mayhem that show. It was like, it was different. It was different totally. Like, yeah, it was good storytelling. I mean, I wouldn't have defined it that way. But I like that. I did say at some point that one, Barbara Walters was ready to retire. Or maybe I said something more heartless like when she died when I was little,
这挺明显的。但嗯，那个节目不仅仅是谋杀和混乱。它是那样的，它是完全不同的。就像，是的，那是很好的讲故事方式。我的意思是，我当时不会那样定义它。但我很喜欢。我确实在某个时候说过，当芭芭拉·沃尔特斯准备退休时。或者也许我说了更无情的话，比如我小时候她去世时，
because you know, you're insensitive as a little kid that I wanted her job. Because it seemed fun. And it seemed like she was not insensitive. No, it's just. I mean, if you said it at a funeral, that would be. And then you know, seven is five, six, seven, eight year olds, you're a little, you came out, you're, you're a little off. Well, is that, now you say you don't have a five year plan, but with that, is that
因为你知道，小孩子总是很迟钝，说我想得到她的工作。因为看起来很有趣。而且看起来她并不是不敏感。不，这只是。我的意思是，如果你在葬礼上这么说，那就……然后你知道，七岁，五、六、七、八岁的孩子，你有点，你当时有点怪怪的。好吧，这，现在你说你没有五年计划，但随着那个，这是否
a natural progression of sort of the lane you're in now, as far as media goes? I mean, I, I, I really, the show the show is about three months old, four months old now. It's so good. It's great. Yeah, you're doing such a great job. You're awesome. Every week, we just try to think of who we want to know more about. Right.
是你现在所处领域的自然发展，就媒体而言？我的意思是，我，我，这个节目大概才三个月大，四个月大。太棒了。太棒了。对，你们做得太棒了。太厉害了。每周我们都在想我们想更多了解谁。对。
And try to have them on as a guest. And what we want to know more about, and then I usually try to spend a couple hours with somebody so that we can do a piece about them that isn't just about the news of the day, but who are they and what are they thinking about? And actually, it's a show I think I would want to watch, but I always thought about what I wanted people to come away with, right?
然后试着请他们来做嘉宾。以及我们想了解更多关于什么的信息，然后我通常会花几个小时和某人在一起，这样我们就能做一个关于他们的专题，不仅仅是关于当天的热闻，而是他们是谁，他们在想什么？实际上，这是一个我想看的节目，但我总是思考我希望人们从中获得什么，对吧？
And I want them to feel like they're learning something about, even about someone, something they didn't know. Maybe it's somebody they didn't think they agreed with. Or whatever. I feel like you'll probably watch a multi-episode series on Is Ron Claim. I bet you could fill a bunch of episodes. I would like to do a bunch of episodes on Ron Claim.
我希望他们觉得自学到了一些东西，哪怕是关于某个人，关于他们不知道的事情。也许是他们原本以为自己不同意的人。或者诸如此类。我觉得你可能会看一部关于罗恩·克莱恩的多集系列纪录片。我敢打赌你可以拍好多集。我很想拍几集关于罗恩·克莱恩的节目。
He is just such. I'm who is that? He was a chief, just go ahead. Yeah, go ahead, go ahead. You know it. He was a chief of staff, right? Biden's first chief of staff. He's now, oh yeah, no longer. Right know, he was a chief chief of staff, right? Biden's first chief of staff. He's now, oh, yeah, yeah, no longer.
他简直太。我是谁？他曾是幕僚长，去吧，说下去。对，说下去，说下去。你知道的。他曾是幕僚长，对吧？拜登的第一任幕僚长。他现在，哦，对，已经不是了。对，你知道的，他曾是幕僚长，对吧？拜登的第一任幕僚长。他现在，哦，对，已经不是了。
Yeah, where did he go? He was a fan. He was a fan of smartness. I heard he. Oh, yeah. I've never talked about. I bet he is. And he, and he, he was hugely instrumental in fixing our COVID situation. Yes. Before he became chief of staff, correct? Yeah. Well, this, this was during... This was in the... Transition, figuring out.
对，他去哪儿了？他是个粉丝。他是个聪明人的粉丝。我听说他。哦，对。我从没谈过。我敢打赌他是。而且他，他，他在解决我们的新冠疫情危机中发挥了巨大的作用。是的。在他成为幕僚长之前，对吧？对。嗯，这，这是在……是在过渡时期，在摸索的时候……
Yeah, I mean, he was one of the smartest people I've ever met and he is a person who doesn't really sleep. And so, one of those people who you go to a meeting with and you think, I'm so prepared, I'm ready for all the things and then he's 400 steps ahead of you. Where'd he go now? What's he doing? He's a law firm.
对，我的意思是，他是见过的最聪明的人之一，而且他是一个几乎不睡觉的人。所以，他是那种你和他开会时会想，我准备得太充分了，我对所有事情都做好了准备，然后他比你领先400步的人。他现在去哪儿了？他在做什么？他在一家律所。
And he has a law firm. And set we've lost, dammit. Yeah, I know. Very nice. How do you, were you privy to confidential information in the White House? Yeah. But the stuff that President knows.
他在一家律所。而我们失去了他，该死。对，我知道。非常好。你在白宫时能接触到机密信息吗？对。但是总统知道的那些东西。
The president knows. He's sorry, sorry. He's trying to work his way towards aliens and UFOs. Oh. Thousands per cent. Thousands per cent. I know, Chris. I know. I knew it. I could split. That was quite person. I know, of course I do. I knew it.
总统知道的。他抱歉，抱歉。他正试图把话题引向外星人和UFO。哦。百分之几千。百分之几千。我知道，克里斯。我知道。我早就知道了。我能预料到。那真是个很好的调侃。我知道，我当然知道。我早就知道了。
I could, I could split. That was quite a flirtation. I was like, where are you going with this? I don't know if I knew who the back guy is. I was just fucking asking about that. Ah, you have a whole piece of that. You know, I will say I had a lot of access to class of that information, but there's this thing
我能，我能预料到。那真是一次精彩的调侃。我当时想，你这是要把话题带到哪儿去啊？我不知道我知不知道那家伙是谁。我刚才只是在瞎问这个。啊，你对此有一整套见解。你知道，我会说我确实接触到了很多分类信息，但有这么个东西
called need to know. And if you don't need to know, you don't necessarily have access to it. And I wasn't on kind of the alien portfolio, your post that wasn't in my- Do you have any boxes in your bathroom at home? I don't, I don't, I don't have boxes in my bathroom. What can we do about the,
叫做“需要知道原则”。如果你不需要知道，你就不一定能接触到它。而且我不在外星人事务的负责范围内，你的那个职位不在我的——你家浴室里有任何箱子吗？我没有，我没有，我家里浴室里没有箱子。我们能对那个
what seems to be a very lightweight, cheesy wood, blue-painted sliding door there for the press room? I'd like, I'd like a switch. Let's switch out something about it. Let's put a glossy blue on it. When you come and you do your tour of Meet the Press and the NBC and MSNBC offices here, we'll take you to, have you been to the briefing room?
看起来非常轻量、廉价的木质、漆成蓝色的推拉门做点什么吗？我想要，我想要换一个。我们换个别的吧。给它刷上一层亮光蓝。当你来参观“与媒体见面”以及这里的 NBC 和 MSNBC 办公室时，我们会带你去看，你去过发布会大厅吗？
You've seen it, right? Have you been in there? At the White House? Yeah. Yes. Okay. It's very sad in there. I know. I think reporters and journalists who are doing amazing work. I mean, it's borderline
你见过，对吧？你进去过吗？在白宫？对。是的。好吧。里面挺让人伤感的。我知道。我认为那些在做惊人工作的记者们。我的意思是，这简直是
disgusting, actually, where they where they work and they do their work. So it needs a whole reboot. Little pocket door. It's so sad that little pocket door. The pocket door. I mean, yeah. Yeah. I know. Now right behind that, right behind that, there seems to be a lot of action right behind that. What do we do? So if you walk out of the briefing room, back into the White House, how far are you from the Oval Office from there? Or was there like a press room right there?
边缘性地糟糕，实际上，他们工作和进行采访的地方。所以它需要彻底重新装修。一个小口袋门。那个小口袋门太让人伤感了。那个口袋门。我是说，对。对。我知道。现在就在那后面，就在那后面，好像有很多活动。我们该怎么走？如果你走出发布会大厅，回到白宫，从那里到椭圆形办公室有多远？还是说那里正好有个新闻办公室？
There's the lower, what's called the lower press office where a lot of the spokespeople sit and journalists can come in and out. Then if you walk up a hallway, if you go to the right, and then one more left to write at the Oval Office, you go to the left, you're in the Rose Garden. Yeah, it's pretty small, right? Yeah, the whole White House is not big.
那里有较低的，也就是所谓的较低新闻办公室，很多发言人和记者可以进进出出。然后如果你走上一条走廊，向右转，再向左转就能到椭圆形办公室，如果你向左转，你就在玫瑰园里。是的，挺小的，对吧？对，整个白宫并不大。
It's very small. I do have a funny story about the pocket door, can I tell you? Yeah, please. The pocket door, in my first year working for Barack Obama, Bill Clinton came to visit and was meeting with him. And they were having this private meeting. It was also during a lot of the holiday parties to a lot of the staff over celebrating Christmas
非常小。我确实有一个关于口袋门的有趣故事，能讲讲吗？好，请讲。在我为巴拉克·奥巴马工作的头一年，比尔·克林顿来访问并与他会面。他们当时在进行一次私人会谈。这也正值许多节日派对期间，许多工作人员都在庆祝圣诞节
and holidays they celebrate. And only one or two, maybe 20 to 23 year olds were staffing the press office in case anyone needed anything. And President Obama, President Clinton came down and we're trying to open that pocket door, which locks. Like Jason on the airplane and the dock. Oh, I don't. There you go. They were trying to open it because, and the 23 or 24-year-old said, can I help you with anything? And they said, we have some things we want to say,
和他们庆祝的节日。新闻办公室里只有一两个大概23岁的年轻人留守，以防任何人需要什么。然后奥巴马总统、克林顿总统走下来，正试图打开那个带锁的口袋门。就像杰森在飞机和码头上那样。哦，我不。给你。他们试图打开它，因为——那个23或24岁的年轻人说：“有什么需要我帮忙的吗？”他们说：“我们有一些事情要对
and share with the press. Now, the reason this is funny, a number of reasons, but one of them is I think they were envisioning that anytime you open that door, there's a bunch of reporters like sitting waiting. Right, right. Yeah. And really, a lot of them were at the holiday party and other things.
媒体说，想与他们分享。”现在，为什么这个故事很有趣呢？有很多原因，但其中之一是，我想他们当时设想的是，无论什么时候你打开那扇门，都会有一群记者坐在那里等待。对，对。是的。而实际上，他们中的许多人当时都在参加节日派对和其他活动。
So they had to go run around and say to the reporters, get in your seats, get a pen, put shoes on, come back to the briefing room, those two presidents are coming in. So yeah, the pockets are some history, I don't know if you wanna get rid of it. And then you've got, and then you've got like those,
所以他们不得不跑来跑去对记者们说：“回到你们的座位上去，拿上笔，穿上鞋，回到发布会大厅，那两位总统要来了。”所以，是的，那个口袋门很有历史感，我不知道你是不是想摆脱它。然后你还有，然后你还有那些，
those stables outside, right? Where the reporters will do their hits from inside there along the driveway, right? The Pebble Beach is what it's called, yeah. Pebble Beach. Why do they call it that? I'm not even sure, but it's kind of a row of cameras.
外面的那些马厩，对吧？记者们会在那里沿着车道进行连线播报，对吧？那里被称为卵石海滩，对吧。卵石海滩。他们为什么那样叫它？我甚至也不太确定，但那里有一排摄像机。
So you think they have the backdrop of the White House? Yeah. They're like individual little sort of cordoned off tents, right? It's like a swanky hotel pool where you got bunch of bananas, right? Something like that, right? I don't know if it's a swing. Yes, or they stand on boxes in the freezing cold when it's raining and tell you what's happening at the White House or something.
所以你觉得他们有白宫作为背景？对。它们就像一个个独立的小型警戒帐篷，对吧？就像一个豪华酒店的游泳池，周围有一束香蕉，对吧？类似于那样，对吧？我不知道是不是这样。是的，或者他们站在严寒中、下雨天的箱子上，告诉你白宫正在发生什么事情或者诸如此类。
Jen, what's your biggest regret? Can I call you Jen? Sure. What else would you call me? I don't know. What's your biggest, I guess Jennifer? What's your biggest regret, or do you have any that you can share with us
珍，你最大的遗憾是什么？我可以叫你珍吗？当然。不然你还能叫我什么？我不知道。你最大的，或者我该叫詹妮弗？你最大的遗憾是什么，或者你有什么可以跟我们分享的遗憾吗？
that you were like, I wish I had done this or said this or responded this way. Do you have a- Every day, every day I did that job. Every day I do a show now, every time I end it, and I say, I wish I would have said this, I wish I said that. I have some more bigger than others.
让你觉得“我真希望当时这么做、这么说或那样回应”。你有没有——每天，我在那份工作上每天都这样。我现在每天做节目，每次节目结束时，我说，我真希望我当时说了这个，我真希望我说了那个。有些遗憾比其他的更大。
Sure, and when you're working on a show, and we've had that ball as performers and actors and stuff, you have those days where you go, I wish that, but I mean more like because of what you were doing when you were working in government. Yeah. And the stakes are so much higher than, as you now see, But I mean more like because of what you were doing when you were working in government. Yeah.
当然，当你在制作节目时——作为表演者和演员，我们也有过这种经历——你会有那种日子，你会想，我希望那样，但我的意思是，更多是因为你在政府工作时的经历。是的。而且风险要高得多，正如你现在所看到的，但我的意思是，更多是因为你在政府工作时的经历。是的。
And the stakes are so much higher than as you now see. Now that you're doing TV, you see how low the stakes really are. When you're actually helping to what you're doing is part of shaping policy and doing all that kind of stuff, did you have any regrets going like, I wish that had gone this way or something like that. Yes. Yeah. Again, you don't have to get specific, but you can just.
而且风险要高得多，正如你现在所看到的。现在你做电视了，你才发现风险其实有多低。当你实际上在帮助——你所做的是塑造政策和做所有那种事情的一部分时，你有没有任何遗憾，觉得“我真希望事情能那样发展”之类的话。是的。是的。再说一次，你不需要说得很具体，但你可以简单说说。
Oh, no, I mean, one, I didn't say there was the president's love confidence in the FBI director on my first day. My first day already had a regret. I kind of made fun of the space force unintentionally because it has a kind of name, but it has an important job. Yeah, because it's a clown show. That we did that. Well, the name is absurd, but it has an important job. Yeah, because it's a clown show. Because the name is absurd, but they do an important job.
哦，不，我的意思是，第一，我在第一天没有说总统对FBI局长充满信心。我的第一天就已经有了遗憾。我无意中开玩笑调侃了太空军，因为它的名字听起来有点怪，但它承担着重要的工作。对，因为它就是一个马戏团表演。我们确实这么做了。嗯，名字确实很荒谬，但它承担着重要的工作。对，因为它就是一个马戏团表演。因为名字确实很荒谬，但他们承担着重要的工作。
Now, to the credit of the guy who was running it, he sent me a note and even a pin. It was very nice. But my biggest one is probably the height of COVID when we were, there was a demand for tests and there was a shortage of tests and people asked me a hundred questions about this every day and this was one of those moments of exasperation where it was like the 19th question about it and I said what do you want us to do send them to every American and that's not actually what we ended up doing because it wouldn't have it would have been a waste but we did end up doing a website where people could order tests.
现在，值得称赞的是，负责那个部门的那位仁兄给我写了便条，甚至还送了一枚徽章。他人非常好。但我最大的遗憾可能是在新冠疫情最高峰的时候，当时对检测的需求很大，检测物资短缺，人们每天问我关于这方面的一百个问题，这是那种由于感到恼火而爆发的时刻之一，当时已经是关于这个问题的第19个问题了，我说：“你们想怎么样，难道把它们发给每个美国人吗？”而这其实并不是我们最终做的事情，因为那样做本不会有效果，那将是一种浪费，但我们最终确实推出了一个网站，让人们可以订购检测盒。
Right, yeah, yeah. And either way, it was just flip in an insensitive and wasn't what I meant at the time. It's just like, I was like, I'm tired of answering this question. But yes, I wish that that would have gone differently, but there's plenty of times. Yeah.
对，没错。不管怎样，那句话显得很轻率、很不敏感，也不是我当时的本意。这就像，我就觉得：我厌倦了回答这个问题。但是，是的，我希望那件事能有不同的结果，不过这样的时刻还有很多。是的。
I have one. There's so many things that were shunned done differently. And he sends them to me. Yeah, it's a different, a different flavor of graders, but that sends them to me. Yeah, I was sure a different flavor of graders, but that's for another comment. Yeah, I know, love that. Now, Jen, we can cut this question or whatever you want,
我有一个。有太多事情如果肖恩来做会有所不同。而且他把它们寄给我。对，是另一种风味的格雷泽冰淇淋，但那是另一回事了。对，我知道，太棒了。现在，珍，我们可以剪掉这个问题或者你想怎么处理都行，
but it's on my list. It's something that I wanted to ask you about. Yeah. We've touched on it before about the massive, you know, the feeling, the sense of division in this country that kind of has never been here before. And being on now both sides, as the press secretary, of division in this country that kind of has never been here before. And being on now both sides as the press secretary and now having your own show, do you think
但它在我的清单上。这是我想问你的事情。是的。我们之前谈到过这个国家大规模的、那种从未有过的分裂感和情绪。作为新闻秘书，你现在身处双方阵营，这种国家的分裂感从未有过，而且你现在有了自己的节目，你认为
the press is to what level of blame, if any, is the press to about the division? Do you think they use too many superlatives and try to draw on these kind of, make the biggest wave out of the story and that story just to get viewer like, or do you think the opposite and the press is just doing their job and they're doing a great job? I mean, from having been on both sides of it, but even I think the majority of press
媒体应该承担多少责任，如果有的话，媒体对这种分裂要负多大责任？你觉得他们是不是用了太多夸张的修辞，试图从这些新闻中挑起轩然大波，把故事炒到最大，仅仅为了获取收视率？还是你觉得恰恰相反，媒体只是在做好他们的本职工作，而且他们做得很好？我的意思是，从经历过双方的角度来看，甚至我认为大多数媒体
are doing a good job and not just doing a good job but doing kind of following their role, which is to kind of get to the bottom of the truth of things, right? I think the majority of reporters, and even though I've only been on this side for not that long, I've worked with reporters and journalists and media for decades, right? So that has always been my belief. There are bad actors and people who do not behave that way and do not and share
都做得很好，不仅是做得好，而且是在恪尽职守，他们的职责就是探究事情的真相，对吧？我认为大多数记者，尽管我在这一边待的时间不长，但我与记者、新闻界和媒体打交道已经几十年了，对吧？所以这一直是我的信念。其中也有一些害群之马，以及那些行为不端、不愿分享
missing. I've been accused of being in that. You correct yourself pretty quickly even when you spread, you know, moments, you have moments. But even for, there's, there are bad actors who spread disinfo, who spread inaccurate information, who escalate things, a lesser violation, I would say, are people who get too freak out about everything, which also is not healthy. Everything is not a crisis. Right. And keep projecting.
失实信息的人。我曾被指控属于那种人。即使你传播了，你也很快会纠正自己，你知道，有时候你会有那样的时刻。但即使对于，有一些害群之马散布虚假信息，散布不准确的信息，把事情升级；我要说，较轻微的违规是那些对每件事都惊慌失措的人，这也是很不健康的。并非每件事都是危机。对。并且不断宣称
Everything is a crisis. People are going to turn off the TV and stop reading the newspaper. Right. So, you can't tell everybody to freak out about everything. That's right. I mean, because, and we even sometimes do segments we call don't freak out because otherwise your nerves are so frayed and you just It's a little boy who cried wolf you don't know when it is actually something that is a crisis and something we should be worried about and not There are there are some people though, you know
每件事都是危机。人们会关掉电视，不再看报纸。对。所以，你不能告诉大家对每件事都惊慌失措。没错。我的意思是，因为，我们有时甚至会做一些名为“别惊慌”的板块，否则你们的神经会高度紧张，而且你会——这就像“狼来了”的故事，当真正发生危机、真正需要我们担心的事情时，你却不知道了，而且不会。不过，确实有些人，你知道的
I have over two thousand employees in Minnesota, you know who would do all need pillows and you know I'm not freaking out about anything Yeah, pretty good. That is is pretty good that's pretty good you know I see Jen talking on the bus of those liberal leaning Hollywood elite on the podcast you know what is what's your favorite a little bit of this interview that you that that you still have from the White House. Oh my God. Either official or that maybe no one knows that you've taken.
我在明尼苏达州有两千多名员工，你知道的，他们都需要枕头，你知道的，我对任何事情都不惊慌。是的，挺不错的。那真的很不错，那真的很不错，你知道的，我看到珍在播客中与那些自由派好莱坞精英谈笑风生，你知道的，你从白宫带出来的最喜欢的一点小纪念品是什么？哦，天哪。无论是官方的还是可能没人知道的你拿走的纪念品。
I'm trusting you can tell us. You can tell what I'm taking. Yeah, you can tell what I'm telling. What if I take it from the White House? I didn't really take much. I do have my briefing book. Okay. I don't know that that's a real White House memorabilia.
我相信你可以告诉我们。你可以说我拿了什么。是的，你可以说我拿了什么。如果我从白宫拿了东西呢？我其实没拿什么。我确实有我的发布会简报手册。好吧。我不知道那算不算真正的白宫纪念品。
It's like from my experience. I don't really take anything off the walls, I would say, because that would be bad. It's stealing. Well stealing. Did your office have windows? Yeah. Your office did have windows.
这就像是我经历的一部分。我其实没有从墙上拿走任何东西，我想说，因为那会很糟糕。那是偷窃。嗯，偷窃。你的办公室有窗户吗？对。你的办公室确实有窗户。
Yeah. There are many that don't, right? Yeah. Were you in the executive building? No, I was in the West Wing. Oh, you were? Yeah. Because you loved that show.? No, I was in the West Wing. Oh, you were. Yeah. Because you loved that show.
对。有很多办公室没有，对吧？你是在行政大楼里吗？不，我在西翼。哦，是吗？对。因为你太喜欢那个节目了。不，我在西翼。哦，是吗？对。因为你太喜欢那个节目了。
Oh, I do. I do love it. Actually, I did not watch the West Wing when it came out. I did watch the whole entire series in 2012 after I left the Obama White House, and it made me go back to government. So I was like a late bloomer of the West Wing, but it brought me back into government.
哦，我确实很喜欢。我确实很喜欢它。事实上，《白宫风云》刚播出时我并没有看。我在2012年离开奥巴马白宫后看完了整部剧，这让我重新回到了政府工作。所以我算是个《白宫风云》的后起之秀，但它把我带回了政府。
I need to watch it. I'm sitting there. You've never watched it? I've never seen it. I've never seen it either. It's such a good show. So your show is there, is it complicated? Because I know it's complicated on the nighttime talk shows
我得看看这部剧。我就坐在那儿。你从来没看过？我从来没看过。我也从来没看过。这是一部非常棒的剧。所以你的节目，这很复杂吗？因为我知道在深夜脱口秀节目中
about booking guests. There's, you know, well, you can't do this show after this show or you've got to leave a couple of months with. Oh, there's some stuff. So, yeah, I'll bet. And I don't want you, I don't want to get you in trouble or make you uncomfortable. But that is part of the job is trying to negotiate the guests, right? Because certain shows want certain guests and then you have to kind of wait your turn or there's a hierarchy.
预约嘉宾是很复杂的。你知道，嗯，你不能在这个节目之后上那个节目，或者你必须给某个节目留出几个月的档期。哦，确实有一些规矩。所以，是的，我敢打赌。我不想让你陷入麻烦，也不想让你感到不舒服。但这也是工作的一部分，就是要努力跟嘉宾进行协商，对吧？因为某些节目想要特定的嘉宾，然后你必须按资排辈或者存在某种阶层。
I'll bet. Well, I don't know if it's a hierarchy as much as you do have to do legwork, reaching out to people and engaging with them about being on your show. And why, you know, you never tell them like, this is what I'm going to ask you or I won't ask you this, but, you know, sometimes I think everybody is different pitches about the experience of their show. So for me, I would tell people, we're going to give you more time, we want to explore more than just the news of the show. So for me, I would tell people, we're gonna give you more time, we wanna explore more than just the news of the day. I wanna go take a walk with you,
我敢打赌。好吧，我不知道这算不算是一种等级制度，但你确实得做很多跑腿工作，去联系人们，邀请他们上你的节目。而且为什么，你知道的，你永远不会告诉他们：“我打算问你这个，或者我不问你那个”，但你知道的，有时我认为每个人对他们节目体验的宣传点都不一样。所以对我和我而言，我会告诉人们，我们会给你更多时间，我们想探讨的不仅仅是节目的新闻。所以对我来说，我会告诉人们，我们会给你更多时间，我们想探讨的不仅仅是当天的热点新闻。我想和你去散步，
we're cook with you, we're run with you, we're whatever, which is a little bit different than other shows. My shows also newer. So some other shows are like, I've been around for a long time, and my viewership is whatever it is. Everybody has different pitches.
和你一起做饭，和你一起跑步，诸如此类，这跟其他节目有点不一样。我的节目也更年轻。所以有些别的节目会说，我已经办了很久了，我的收视群就是这样。每个人都有不同的宣传点。
But you gotta do some leg work on it, and do your homework. I mean, I'm always, because I've been all sides of the pitches of things, I always laugh. I mean, I can't even imagine the number of pitches people you all get for, I don't even know. But people send me emails to pitch being on the show that it's like, have you ever watched the show?
但你必须在这上面下点功夫，做好功课。我是说，我总是——因为我经历过各种各样的宣传，所以我总是觉得好笑。我是说，我甚至无法想象你们所有人收到了多少宣传邮件，我都不知道。但人们发邮件给我，毛遂自荐想上节目，那感觉就像：你看过这档节目吗？
I mean, it's hasn't been around that long, but there are like things that have nothing to do with what we do. Well, then wanting the right show. Yeah, yeah. And so around that long, but there are like things that have nothing to do with what we do. Well, then wanting to do the right show. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. And so, you know, it's from well-meaning PR people. That's completely fine.
我的意思是，它开播时间也没那么长，但有些内容跟我们做的事情毫无关系。哦，然后他们想要合适的节目。对，对。所以开播时间也没那么长，但有些内容跟我们做的事情毫无关系。哦，然后他们想要做好节目。对，对，对。所以，你知道的，这是出于好意的公关人员。这完全没问题。
I respect the profession. But what I've learned is you really have to do the homework and read the 20 articles about a person to say, I thought it was so interesting about this or that or what would have you. So, yeah, you got to do, you got to do, but thinking of course, there's like a little competition about who has who and all that kind of
我尊重这个行业。但我学到的是，你真的必须做好功课，读完关于一个人的20篇文章，然后说：“我觉得这或那或者随便什么地方很有意思。”所以，是的，你得去做，你得去做，不过当然啦，大家会觉得，谁请到了谁，这之间其实有点小竞争，诸如此类。
Sure, but if somebody likes to say Andrew Weisman is like on salary Basically like it was is he told what shows to do or does he get to pick what shows he does He he gets to pick what shows he does but but if people like to watch him all day Oh, he's the best isn't he and you do and you do and he has a dog name in us I've been to his apartment. We did a whole second. That apartment is just shooting. It's right up here.
当然，但如果有人喜欢——比如安德鲁·威斯曼（Andrew Weissman）基本上是有薪水的，是有人告诉他该做哪个节目，还是他自己挑选节目？他自己挑节目。但是，如果人们整天都喜欢看他哦，他最棒了，不是吗？你做到了，你做到了，他还有一只叫诺斯的狗。我去过他的公寓。我们拍了整整一小段。那公寓简直就在拍照。就在上面。
We rule. We rule. It must be out of there. He always scores highly. We rule. He's got art. You can't even see in the apartment. I've always got the metal stick.
我们太棒了。我们太棒了。它一定不在那儿。他总是得分很高。我们太棒了。他有艺术品。你甚至在公寓里都看不见。我总是拿着金属棒。
You know, you've got good art if you're not showing it. You know what I'm saying? I mean, the people book people up. they kind of lock them in if they know because the legal story is going to be big for a while. It seems that's my most diplomatic way of saying it. So you get to decide your fill-in when you go on vacation, you get to decide who takes over for you or is that your call from the high up? Yeah, I think so. I think you kind of have a conversation. I haven't missed a show yet.
你知道的，如果不拿出来展示，就说明你的艺术品位很好。你知道我的意思吗？我是说，那些负责预约嘉宾的人……他们会把人锁定，因为他们知道法律官司在一段时间内会是个大新闻。我觉得这是我最外交辞令的说法了。所以你度假时可以自己决定谁来替班吗？这由高层决定，还是由你说了算？对，我想是这样的。我想你们会商量一下。我还没缺席过一期节目呢。
So I don't know yet. Yeah, all right. Well, you can go on for Oscar I'm not asking for me. Yeah, I'm Jen Saki. You're taking away too much of your time. I we love you like two minutes Yeah, I want to I want to leave with with this Jen because and I really mean it. I want to say thank you for always imbuing the idea and the sense that every human being should be treated equal. And you've always said versions of that throughout your entire career. I don't understand who wouldn't be for that idea that all human beings should be created equal. But so thank you for all of your time. You've always seemed to be a very decent person. Thank you. I believe that. I mean, in a lot of
所以我还不知道。好吧，你可以为了奥斯卡去……我不是为了我自己。是的，我是珍·萨基（Jen Psaki）。你占用了太多时间。我们爱你，就两分钟。是的，我想——珍，我想以这个结束，我是认真的。我想对你说声谢谢，谢谢你一直以来都在宣扬这样一种理念和意识：每个人都应该被平等对待。在你的整个职业生涯中，你一直都在表达类似的话。我不明白怎么会有人不支持所有人类生来平等的理念呢。所以，非常感谢你抽出时间。你一直以来都是一个非常正派的人。谢谢。我相信这一点。我是说，在很多
ways, I don't see myself as a partisan or as a Democrat, even though I've worked in Democratic pugs, I see myself as somebody who believes in kind of morally what is right and not justifying discrimination. And that is what gets me. It came across. Well, you're very exciting to listen to and to watch because of your intellect, and your, some people can have an intellect, but they're kind of old and stodgy, but there's a current, there's a relevance to your sensibility about things
方面，我不觉得自己是个党派人士，也不觉得自己是民主党人，尽管我在民主党阵营工作过。我觉得自己是一个信仰某种道德正义、反对歧视的人。而这正是我所追求的。这很容易让人理解。好吧，听你说话、看你节目非常令人兴奋，因为你的才华，有些人虽然有才华，但有点老气横秋、古板僵化，而你的审美却有一种时代的脉搏、一种紧跟潮流的敏锐度
and your way in which that you articulate that is always exciting to listen to. So thank you. Thank you so much. So great to meet you. Huge fan. Happy third birthday. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And good luck to the show. We'll keep watching. Thank you so much. Thanks Jen.
而且你表达的方式总是让人听了心潮澎湃。所以谢谢你。非常感谢。很高兴认识你。超级粉丝。祝三岁生日快乐。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。祝节目越办越好。我们会继续收看的。非常感谢。谢谢你，珍。
Thank you. Bye. What about that Jen? Jen, I love you. Jen, I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. You know, anybody with a silent pee, especially, especially with, she should open the sushi plays, right? Jen Saki.
谢谢。再见。那个珍怎么样？珍，我爱你。珍，我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。你知道的，名字里带个不发音的p的人，尤其是，尤其是她应该去开家寿司店才对，对吧？珍·萨基。
Yeah. Exactly. I saw that coming from a mile away. And Jay, she was on a list for a while, right? She was, yeah, but, you know, I mean, I, I've got a lot of, I don't push for the political folks because I know we try not to get too political on the show, but man, I've got a lot of, I don't push for the political folks because I know we try not to get too political on the show. But man, I've got a long list of folks. I should maybe, I should, I should start a different podcast.
对。没错。我早就料到了。而且杰伊，她有一阵子在候选名单上对吧？她确实在，但是，你知道的，我是说，我有好多——我不大愿意催促政治界的人士，因为我知道我们尽量不在节目里涉及太多政治，但是天哪，我有一长串名单。也许我应该，我应该，我应该开个别的播客。
Yeah, one on the side, right? But yeah, I'm, I'm fascinated with all that political stuff, especially now. Well, I just, and I love the way she said, Sean, in sort of, in answering your question at the end when you were talking, but just about this idea that she's not trying to be one way or the other, like in fact, if anything, she just wants to come across as very... Bye, partisan!
对，私下搞一个，对吧？但是，是的，我对所有这些政治八卦都很着迷，尤其是现在。我只是——我喜欢她最后回答你问题时那种方式，肖恩，当你说话的时候，就是关于她不想表现得偏向任何一边这种想法，事实上，如果非要说的话，她只是想给人留下非常……再见，党派！
Oh, nice, bye! She works for Joe Biden! You still have! Don't organize! You can't organize the pie! Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umgerf. Smart loss. This episode was recorded on July 11th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts,
哦，太棒了，再见！她为乔·拜登工作！你还有！不要组织！你不能组织派对！Smartless是由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbakow）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·乌姆格弗（Rob Ungerf）100%纯天然手工打造的。Smartless。本集录制于7月11日。我们的下一集将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，
or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondri app. But the new podcast Sports Explains the World brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank. Diving into his Wikipedia page we turned three career goals into 11 and added 20 new assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident? Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous.
或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上的Wondery Plus或Wondery App抢先收听且无广告。但是新播客《体育解释世界》（Sports Explains the World）为你带来了一些你从未听过的最疯狂、最令人惊异的体育故事，比如那个为年轻运动员写了假维基百科页面，然后眼睁睁看着一支真正的球队上当受骗的少年。深入研究他的维基百科页面，我们将3个职业进球变成了11个，并顺便增加了20次助攻。这数据本来谁都不该、也不该相信。以及一个在职业生涯巅峰期遇害的美国奥运巨星的神秘秘密。这是一场意外吗？警察把调查搞砸了吗？一切都那么扑朔迷离。
Each week, Sports Explains the World goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports, and their impact on the world. Listen to sports explains the world, on the Wondry app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每周，《体育解释世界》超越了联赛和数据，分享那些将重新定义你对体育及其对世界影响的理解的故事。在Wondery App或你获取播客的任何地方收听《体育解释世界》。你可以在Wondery Plus上提前收听无广告的《体育解释世界》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。